TO OUR FIRST HEARING OF SUB
FIVE WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
WHO HERE COLLEGE EYES FOR
THINGS OVERLAPPING
UNFORTUNATELY IN MY OFFICE AND
SO- WAS DELAYED IN GETTING HERE
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR OUR
FIRST MEETING. OUR AGENDA TODAY
IS NOT A VERY LONG TWO ITEMS-
BUT WE HOPE THAT THE THAT
AGENDA WILL BE INFORMATIVE AND
HELPFUL- WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH ITEM. FIFTY TWO TWENTY
FIVE AND THE FIRST ON THE
ASACOL THE ROLE. WEBER HERE
JONES SAWYER LACKEY. MELENDEZ
STONE HEY WE DO HAVE A QUORUM-
WE'RE NOT VOTING ON ANY ITEMS
TODAY BUT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
FOR THE MEETING SO WE'RE GONNA
BEGIN WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS ALL ISSUES UNDERNEATH
THE DEPARTMENT TO CALVIN PART
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION OF ONE TO DEAL
WITH THE POPULATION OVER VIEW
IN THE GOVERNOR'S UP PRISON
CLOSURE PROPOSAL- SO WILLOWS
WHO ARE SCHEDULED TO PRESENT
THE PALACE SOMEONE FROM CDC
OUR- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S AND DON
SPECTER WHO WAS A PRISON LAW
OFFICE.
BUT. THEY WERE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH THE CDC ARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR WOMAN- GOOD
AFTERNOON AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
THESE TWO REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUES ONE ABOUT THE POPULATION
IN THE NEXT SUBJECT REGARDING
THE ALLEGATION INQUIRE
MANAGEMENT SECTION. BUT YOU
KNOW FIRST OF ALL I WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE POPULATION HAS
REALLY BEEN ON THE SUBJECT-
THAN THIS OF THE A LOT OF
CONVERSATION I'VE BEEN WITH-
WITH PEOPLE AND- I'LL JUST SORT
OF WITH THE RAW NUMBERS AS OF
THIS MORNING WE ARE AT- HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND AND
TWENTY THREE INMATES. THAT
FIGURE REPRESENTS ABOUT FOUR
FIVE FORTY TWO THOUSAND INMATES
LESS SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN. THAT'S ABOUT 2025%
REDUCTION OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS. THE POPULATION QUESTION
ASKED SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
REDUCTIONS AND THAT'S A LOT OF
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE BEEN
HAVING REDUCTIONS IN WHAT. WHAT
WE CAN DO AS A DEPARTMENT TO
BRING DOWN FACILITIES EVER
SINCE THE GOVERNOR MADE. I
THINK- THE RIGHT COMMENT IN
THAT WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
WE WILL BRING DOWN A FACILITY.
BUT FOR ME AS A SECRETARY-
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNICATING. TO THE AGENCIES
AS BIG AS IT IS- I THINK  HAVE
TO LOOKING AT THE COMMUNICATE
BEYOND THE NUMBERS ITSELF. THE
NUMBERS TO ME REPRESENT PEOPLE.
I THINK WHAT ON THE SURFACE
EVERY BEING BEHIND EVERY PERSON
IS A NUMBER WOULD NEEDS
CONCERNS AND EARS- THAT'S
EVERYONE INVOLVED THAT'S THE
INMATE POPULATION THAT THE
STAFF IN THE COMMUNITY AND
EVERYBODY THAT COMES IN PROVIDE
SERVICES. INTO THE INSTITUTION-
THIS FOR ME THIS CHANGE OF
THINKING FROM NUMBERS TO
PEOPLE. REALLY PART OF THE
TRANSFORMATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND HOW WE ARE
RECOGNIZING. OUR OUR
REQUIREMENT TO REACH THE NEEDS
OF THE INDIVIDUAL THAT ARE SENT
TO US. TO PREPARE THEM FOR THE
ONE DAY THAT WILL BE RETURNING
HOME. THE EMPLOYEES THE CDC ARE
SEEK- I BELIEVE THE SECRET
GREATER PURPOSE. BASIC THE
ABILITY TO REACH INDIVIDUALS
BEYOND YEARS PAST WHEN WE WERE
JUST REALLY HOUSING PEOPLE- THE
DAYS OF OVERCROWDING- WHICH WAS
NOT A GOOD DAY. THE DAYS AND WE
HAD A LOT OF STATE WHEN WE HAD
MORE IN STATE WE HAD IN TRIPLE
BONTA WE HAD A MAN DAY ROOMS-
IT'S A DIFFERENT DAY. IN
CORRECTIONS WE HAVE CHALLENGES
AND WE HAVE SOME ISSUES TO TAX.
IN A BETTER. I BELIEVE LONG
PURPOSE REALLY TO TAKE A LOOK
AT OUR POPULATION OF MORE POINT
OF THE STAFF TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN THE
DEPARTMENT ONE OF THE THINGS I
AM CONCERNED WITH ON TOP OF
INMATE REHABILITATION REENTRY
IS ALSO THE EMPLOYEES THAT
PROVIDE THE SERVICES. BECAUSE
THEY ALSO ARE AFFECTED AND I
BELIEVE THESE POPULATION
REDUCTIONS HAVE HELPED US IN A
PROVIDE DISABILITY TO CHANGE
HOW WE REACH THE INMATES ARE
SENT TO US FROM THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT-
IF YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY PLEASE
TAKE A LOOK AT THE VISION AND
MISSION STATEMENT. THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION HAS RECENTLY
CHANGED. IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
IT IT IS QUITE DIFFERENT THAN
IT WAS YEARS AGO IT IS MORE A
MISSION STATEMENT THAT'S- MORE
DRIVEN TOWARDS THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE ULTIMATE
GOAL OF RE ENTRY. BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT THEY CAN JUST
GOING BACK TO THE POPULATION
QUESTION. THE REDUCTIONS HAVE
BEEN MADE POSSIBLE BY. TOO MANY
AVENUES THROUGH A VARIETY OF
LEGISLATION VOTER APPROVED
INITIATIVES. SOME OF THEM
INCLUDE AND I WON'T GET INTO
THE DETAILS AB ONE OH NINE
PROPERTY SIX PROP FORTY SEVEN
AND MOST RECENTLY. PROP FIFTY
SEVEN. WHICH I BELIEVE. HAS
REALLY CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE OF
CORRECTIONS AND HOW ARE STAFF
OR PROVIDING SERVICES TO THE
INMATES. AND FOCUSING ON
PUTTING THE ARE IN ITS RIGHTFUL
PLACE IN REHABILITATION THE CDC
ARE. IT WAS CHANGED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX BUT I. YOU
KNOW JUST THROUGH THE RECESSION
IN TOUGH TIMES. IT REALLY MEANS
MORE NOW THAN IN TIME ELSE-
WE'RE DEALING WITH LESS
INMATES. WERE DEALING WITH THE
ABILITY TO RUN. A DIFFERENT
WAY. TO PROVIDE BETTER REENTRY
COMMUNICATING WITH A PROBATION
PARTNERS- AND ALSO THE
COMMUNITY. TO LET THEM KNOW
WHAT THE IMAGE ARE BEING
PROVIDED WHEN THEY DO GO HOME.
AND TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
CONTINUITY OF CARE STATUS WITH
THEM- WHAT WE HAVE- INCREASED-
UNDER THE AUTHORITY CREDIT
EARNINGS AND INTOTHIS
WAR CREDIT FOR INMATES
PARTICIPATING IN. VARIOUS REHAB
PROGRAMS INCLUDING HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE PROGRAMS FACE FACE
COLLAGEN THIRTY FOUR OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS. IT'S LIKE NO
OTHER AND NOW WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION COMING UP FOR
THE INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER TREATMENT WHICH I
THINK IS A- IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN LONG OVERDUE IN OUR PRISON
SYSTEM. THE ONE PIECE OF THE-
POPULATION REDUCTIONS THAT
DON'T THAT DOESN'T TALKED ABOUT
VERY MUCH AND THAT'S THE
AUTHORITY VESTED IN CORRECTIONS
IN THE ELEVEN SEVENTY D. IN THE
PENAL CODE. AND WHAT THAT DOES
IT ALLOW THE SECRETARY TO REFER
INMATES BACK TO SENSING COURSE
FOR VARIOUS REASONS EITHER
CHANGES IN LOS SENSING
DISCREPANCIES- BUT ALSO I THINK
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT ONES IT'S
TO- REFER CASES. BACK TO
FENCING COURTS RECOGNIZING THE
INMATES HAVE CHANGED. AND WE
CAN SHOW THE SENSE IN COURT
HELEN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN
SENTENCED HAS CHANGED AND- FOUR
CENTS IN RECONSIDERATION. WHAT
THAT'S BEEN DOING INSTEAD OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS INMATES ARE
SEEKING OUT REHABILITATION LIKE
NO OTHER TIME- THEY ARE.
ACTIVELY TRYING TO REESTABLISH
FAMILY TIES AND ACTIVELY TRYING
TO BETTER THEMSELVES NOT ONLY
FOR THEMSELVES BUT FOR THE
COMMUNITY THEY LIVE IN IN THESE
PRISONS IN THESE PRESENT THEM
PARTICULAR THESE PRISON YARDS.
SO IT'S BEEN VERY BENEFICIAL-
BEYOND THE CRITICAL ITEMS THAT-
BUT I SPOKEN ABOUT I THINK
CORRECTION OF THE HOLD THE
POPULATION REDUCTION CAN BE
ATTRIBUTED. TO THE PARTNERSHIP
THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED OF THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
PROGRAMS LIKE DOT PROGRAMS THAT
WE'VE NEVER HAD IN THE PAST
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE COMEIN
THAT- TEN FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT OF AS- OR
HOW HOW COULD THAT. BENEFIT ANY
IN MAY BUT IF YOU COME INTO AN
INSTITUTION TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS PARTICULAR
THE DOG PROGRAM. IN VARIOUS
INSTITUTIONS THIS CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC OF WHAT WE HAVE FOUND
IS THAT IMAGE OR SEEKING A
PURPOSE A GREATER PURPOSE. AND
WHAT GREATER PURPOSE IS TO. PUT
A LIVING AN ENTITY A DOG IN
FRONT OF THEM TO TRAIN THEM TO
HELP PEOPLE BE ON THEMSELVES
EVERYTHING FROM VETERANS
SUFFERING FROM PTSD AND OTHER
NEEDS. DISABLED DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS TO TRAIN THEM TO
ASSIST OF THE FIFTH AND DOGS.
AND THEN ALSO JUST THE MORE
STANDARD RESCUE. THE INMATES OF
POURED BACK INTO THESE- INTO
THESE DOGS BUT- THAT DOES THIS
CHANGE THE ATMOSPHERE IN THE
PRISONS- THOSE ARE JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES- I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THROUGH THE AMBITIOUS-
POPULATION REDUCTION THAT WE'VE
UNDERTAKEN WE HAVE. TAKEN DOWN
OUR PRISON FROM ON THE STATE.
WHICH IS A GOOD THING- WERE NOW
IN LINE TO BRING DOWN- THE LAST
OF OUR TO PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
PRISONS- BY APRIL OF NEXT
MONTH. BUT THEN WE ALSO HAVE. A
PLAN TO BRING DOWN OUR-
MODIFIED COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES WHICH REALLY
CONTRACTED WITH- SHAFTER TAFT
AND MAKE FOR AN DELANO. AND
THOSE ARE GOING TO BE COMING
DOWN IN THE LATEST ONE IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SO FOR THAT
A BELIEVER IN A BETTER PLACE
AND WHAT THAT'S ALLOWED US TO
DO IS UTILIZE SPACE BETTER- TO
PUT LESSEN MASON AREAS THAT WE-
THAT WE USED TO HAVE
OVERCROWDED BUT- I THINK THE
USE OF OUR GYMS THE MORE USE OF
SPACE AND LESS INMATES
ILLUSTRIS ON STAFF IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS WE CAN
DO LASTLY A CLOSE WITH- TO
SUSTAIN THESE CHANGES AND
REDUCTION JUST NOT JUST FOR THE
SAKE OF BRINGING INMATES DOWN A
POPULATION DOWN. PROP FIFTY
SEVEN WAS REALLY PUT THEIR TO
ENHANCE INMATES ACCESS TO
REHABILITATION AND HAVE THEM
SEE CUT REHABILITATION IN WAYS
I NEVER DID IN THE PAST. I KNOW
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT PROFIT THE
SEVEN IT REALLY FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF. BLOWING UP
PRISON NUMBERS GETTING PEOPLE
OUT FASTER. BUT THE I THINK THE
POPULATION REDUCTION AS A
PERTAINS TO FIFTY SEVEN I THINK
THAT'S- A BENEFIT. TO THE
INMATE SEEKING REHABILITATION
AND SEEKING TO BETTER
THEMSELVES. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
CREDITS AND INCENTIVES. IMAGE
TO PARTICIPATE IN PROGRAMS NOT
JUST TO GET OUT OF PRISON NOT
JUST TO GET OUT SOONER. THEY
HAVE TO GET OUT AT THE RIGHT
TIME WITH THE RIGHT DOSAGE AND
THEY'VE KERN THESE THINGS
PARTICIPATING IN COURSES IN
ACHIEVING- MASTERY OF SKILLS IN
CERTAIN PROGRAM SO- I'M VERY
LOOKING FORWARD TO- THAN WHAT
SOME OF THESE THAT REDUCTION TO
BRING US- AND I KNOW SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT COME UP
ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHICH PRISON
NEXT AND I'M SURE THIS CAN BE A
VERY. YOU KNOW POINT A TOPIC IN
MY- OTHERS A BRING UP IT IS BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THAT. THESE
AREN'T EASY TASK TO BRING.
STATE OWNED PRISONS DOWN IS NOT
AN EASY THING TO DO- BECAUSE-
ALL POPULATIONS AREN'T CREATED
THE SAME AND THEY'RE NOT HOUSE
THE SAME OR THEY'RE NOT TREATED
THE SAME THERE ARE THESE- SUB
SUB POPULATIONS THAT HAVE
NEEDS- THAT ARE REQUIRED IN
CERTAIN INSTITUTIONS AND
THERE'S ALSO THE STAFF TO
CONSIDER AS WE BRING THEM DOWN-
AND ANY. YOU KNOW ANY
CONSIDERATION OR ANY-
VOCALIZATION OF THIS PRISON ON
THIS DAY IT THERE'S UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES BY COMING OUT TOO
EARLY BY SAYING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT SO I WILL END WITH THAT
AND- I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE. ABILITY TO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CAITLYN
O'NEILL WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M GONNA BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT CALLED
EFFECTIVELY MANAGING STATE
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE- IN THE SERGEANTS HAVE
EXTRA COPIES. I TURNING TO PAGE
ONE THE STATE PRISON SYSTEM HAS
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS A RECENT STUDY FOUND OF
THE STATE'S TWELVE OLDEST
PRESENCE RECOMMENDED OVER
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN-
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES THAT
THE- FOR THE STATE TO MAKE IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
THOSE PRISONS IN THE LONG TERM-
OTHER INFORMATION SUGGESTS THAT
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT NEEDS AT
THIS. THE OTHER TWENTY TWO
STATE OWNED PRISONS THAT AGAIN
COULD PUT IT IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
TURNING A PAGE TO PAGE TWO. THE
SEE A FIGURE HERE SHOWING THAT
THE STATE INMATE POPULATION HAS
BEEN DECLINING IN RECENT YEARS
AND IS PROJECTED TO CONTINUE TO
DECLINE THIRD JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AND RECENT
DECLINES HAVE. BEEN
ACCOMMODATED BY REMOVING
INMATES FROM. OUT OF STATE
CONTRACT FACILITIES FOLLOWED
BY- IN STATE CONTRACT
FACILITIES. THAT ARE PRIVATELY
OPERATED IN HOUSE MALE INMATES
AS REQUIRED BY STATE LAW- THE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING ITS-
ANTICIPATES THAT THE REMAINDER
OF THOSE. I OF INMATES IN THOSE
FACILITIES WILL BE REMOVED BY
APRIL THIS OF THIS SPRING.
AFTER THAT- THE STATE CAN
CHOOSE AS TO WHETHER TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT A FURTHER
DECLINES- BY REMOVING INMATES
FROM PUBLICLY OPERATED
CONTRACTS LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA. OR PROCEED TO
CLOSING PRISONS. AND WE
ESTIMATE THAT GIVEN THIS THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE PROJECT TO
DECLINE AFTER AGAIN AFTER THE
FINAL- INMATES ARE REMOVED FROM
THE PRIVATE FACILITIES HOUSING
MALES. THERE WILL BE ABOUT A
TWENTY TWO SIXTY TWO HUNDRED
AND MAY DECLINE WITH BY JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS
ENOUGH TO CLOSE TO PRESENCE.
AND MOVING ON TO PAGE FOUR I WE
JUST RELEASED A REPORT ON
FRIDAY WHICH I AND I HAVE
COPIES OF HERE IF ANYONE WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE ONE WITH THEM- AND
I'M GOING TO JUST GIVE SOME
VERY BRIEF- TAKE AWAYS FROM THE
REPORT AS IT PERTAINS TO THIS
CONVERSATION BUT I'M CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO- ANSWER QUESTIONS ON
THE REPORTER TALK AT A LATER
DATE IN MORE DETAIL. ABOUT THAT
IF I'D BE HELPFUL- BUT OUR
REPORT- ESSENTIALLY- RECOMMENDS
A ROADMAP TO GUIDE THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A PLAN TO STRATEGICALLY
MANAGE PRESENT INFRASTRUCTURE-
IN LIGHT OF THE POOR CONDITION
OF STATE FACILITIES AND THE
POSSIBILITY OF PRISON CLOSURE
IN THE NEAR TERM. AND WE
RECOMMEND- THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT CD START TO CLOSE TO
PRISONS IN THE NEAR TERM. THIS
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE TO AVOID-
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS AT
THOSE TWO PRESENTS AND THEN
CONCENTRATE- REMAINING EFFORTS
AND RESOURCES AT THE OTHER
PRISONS THAT ARE AND
SIGNIFICANT NEED OF REPAIR.
WHICH WE THINK WOULD REDUCE-
REDUCE THE REST OF STATUS SUED
FOR THE RESULTING ACT THE
CONDITIONS RESULTING FROM POOR
INFRASTRUCTURE- CLOSING TO
PRISONS WOULD ALSO RESULT IN
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION AN
ANNUAL OPERATIONAL SAVINGS
RELATIVE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO.
REMOVE AN FOR INMATES FROM
PUBLIC CONTRACTS AND THEN CLOSE
ONE AT PRESENT WE ALSO
RECOMMEND REQUIRING CDC ARE TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGY TO IMPROVE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE REMAINING
PRESENCE- AND THAT WOULD
INVOLVE. THEM SUBMITTING A LIST
OF THE SIGNIFICANT HIGH
PRIORITY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THEY THINK ARE
NECESSARY OVER THE NEXT AT TEN
YEARS AS WELL AS- SUBMITTING A-
RECOMMENDED PROJECT PRIORITY
ORDER AND TIMELINE- AND- THAT-
PRIORITIZES ISSUES THAT
THREATEN THE IN MAINE STAFF
WELL BEING AS WELL AS-
CONSIDERS OPPORTUNITIES TO
REDUCE COSTS IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS. BETWEEN THE DETAILS-
FURTHER IN OUR REPORT. AND
FINALLY ON PAGE FIVE I'M JUST
GOING TO GOING TO A BIT MORE
DETAIL ON THE STEPS RELATED TO
PRISON CLOSURE GIVEN THAT'S A
KEY TOPIC FOR TODAY- WE- WE
GET. RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY A RANK
PRISONS FOR CLOSURE- BASED ON
KEY CARD KEY CRITERIA WE THINK
THE STATE SHOULD CONSIDER
CLOSING PRISONS WITH HIGH
OPERATIONAL COSTS- INDOOR
COSTLY INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
RELATIVE TO THE AMOUNT OF IN
MAKE CAPACITY THAT THEY GIVE TO
THE SYSTEM. AND THE STATE WE-
WE WOULD ALSO WANT TO LIKELY
AVOID THE CLOSING- OR BE
COGNIZANT OF THE IMPACTS OF
CLOSING PRISONS WITH.
SPECIALIZED MISSIONS FOR
EXAMPLE PRISONS THAT ARE
SPECIALIZED IN PROVIDING THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF HEALTH CARE
TO INMATES. I'M AND THEN THIRD
THE- PRISONS THAT HAVE
DIFFICULTY PROVIDING ADEQUATE
SERVICES DUE TO THEIR LOCATION
FOR EXAMPLE- DIFFICULTY IN
RECRUITING RECRUITING STAFF-
DUE TO THEIR LOCATION- COULD BE
PART TIED FOR CLOSURE OVER
OTHER PERSONS THAT OPERATE MORE
EFFECTIVELY. AND ANY OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO IDENTIFY
OTHER CRITERIA THAT IT WOULD
LIKE TO BE CONSIDERED- IN NOT
RANKING. AND THEN WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE A
DETAILED PRISON CLOSURE PLAN BY
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
THAT WOULD OUTLINED IT
ESSENTIALLY DRESS THE KEY
LOGISTICS- THAT WOULD NEED TO.
HAPPEN TO- FACILITATE A PRISON
CLOSURES. I'M AND THEN AS A
PART OF THAT PLAN- AND CLOSURE
PROCESS THE STATE WILL LIKELY
BARGAIN WITH UNIONS TOO AND
WITH THE UNIONS REPRESENT
EMPLOYEES WHO WORK AT THE
PRESENTS- TO MINIMIZE THE
EFFECTS ON THE WORK FORCE AND
DAY TO DAY OPERATION SO WE
WOULD WANT TO SEE THAT- THOSE.
AT UNION THE PRODUCT OF THOSE
UNION NEGOTIATIONS ALSO
SUBMITTED WITH THE PLAN SO THEY
COULD BE CONSIDERED TOGETHER.
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ROBERT NELSON PART OF FINANCE.
AS NOTED BY SECRETARY DEUS IF
THE CURRENT DOWNWARD POPULATION
TREND CONTINUES WE WILL.
CONTINUE ELIMINATING CONTRACT
FACILITIES THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND EVALUATE
OPTIONS TO CLOSE IN A STATE
PRISON BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. I
LIKE TO KNOW THAT ABILITY TO
CLOSE FACILITIES DEPENDS ON THE
CURRENT POPULATION TREND
HOLDING I'D LIKE TO NOTE. THAT
A NUMBER OF FACTORS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED BEFORE SELECTING
WHICH PRESENT A CLOSE SUCH AS
WE HAVE MADE SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENTS IN RECENT YEARS IN
BUILDING CAPACITY. FOR
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES TO
INMATES IN STATE PRISONS. ANY
OF OUR REHABILITATION IS
EXPECTED TO BE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE MILLION. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. COMPARED TO THREE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWELVE
THIRTEEN. OUR STATE PRISON
PRISONS OFFER A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMMING SUCH AS FACE TO
FACE COLLEGE AN INTEGRATED
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROGRAM. BUT THE PRISON TOO
EARLY COULD IMPEDE THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF ITS INMATE
POPULATION FROM US FISCAL
STANDPOINT CLOSER TO PRISON
BEFORE A CONTRACT FACILITIES IS
NOT CLEAR CUT. IS NOT COMPARING
HIS SON APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON IN GENERAL THE
INMATES WE SEND CONTRACTORS
CITIES ARE CHEAPER TO HOUSE THE
NOSE IN STATE PRISONS FOR
EXAMPLE. ARE CONTRA BEDS ARE
LOWER SECURITY. IT FINALLY
CLOSING THE STATE PRISON BEFORE
CONDUCT CONTRADICT AS SILLY AS
WOULD DIFFER CONSIDERABLE
SAVINGS A SHORT TERM WHILE
KEEPING THOSE CONTRA BEDS OPEN-
WE HAVE THE ANSWER QUESTIONS
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS. THANK
YOU THANK. THANK YOU DONALD
SPECTOR FROM THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE. FIRST OF ALL I AGREE
WITH- SECRETARY DENIES THAT THE
POPULATION AS- GONE WAY DOWN A
SINCE THE COURT ORDERED THE
POPULATION DECREASED AND AS A
RESULT THINGS ARE MUCH BETTER
THAN THEY WERE AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THERE HAS BEEN
MORE REHABILITATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE IN
PRISON THAN THERE EVER HAVE
BEEN BEFORE SO WE CAN GRADUALLY
THE ADMINISTRATION AND MISTER
DE AS AN AS FOLKS FOR DOING ALL
THAT- SECONDLY- PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND THAT. CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS
ARE STILL VERY OVERCROWDED- BY
THEIR OWN ESTIMATE SYSTEM WIDE
THERE AT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
30% OF WHAT THEY WERE DESIGNED
FOR SOME PRISONS ARE AT A
HUNDRED AND 60% OF WHAT THEY
WERE DESIGNED FOR AND MANY ARE
IN THE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY RANGE. SO THE
DON'T WANT TO COMMIT THE HAVE
THE IMP. THE WE'RE OP. AFTER A
SYSTEM WHICH IS AN OVERCROWDED
IT IS VERY OVERCROWDED AND
SQUAT. IT CAUSES A LOT OF
LOGISTICAL PROBLEMS. IN
OPERATING THAT SYSTEM- MANY OF
WHICH MISTER DE AS HESTER ARE.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH- AS
FAR AS THE- CLOSURE OF THE
PRISONS US IS CONCERNED- WE
AGREE WITH THE LA OWES
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK THEY
THOUGHT FALL AND I THINK THEY
SET OUT ON. A PROCESS BY WHICH
THAT CAN HAPPEN. IN TERMS OF
THE POPULATION REDUCTION THIS
ISN'T A IT'S BEEN PRESENTED AS
SOMETHING PASSIVE. IN THE SENSE
OF WELL IF THE POPULATION TREND
CONTINUES HOWEVER THE STATE HAS
CONTROL OVER THE POPULATION IN
TWO WAYS ONE. IF THROUGH THE
PAROLE BOARD- AND SECONDLY
THROUGH PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN
THE SECRETARY OF CORRECTIONS
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO AWARD
CREDITS- AND THE AMOUNT OF
CREDITS SO- IN MY OPINION THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THE ABILITY. TO
MAINTAIN A DECREASE IN
POPULATION THROUGH THOSE TWO
MECHANISMS THE THIRD- GOING TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AS THE LA OO
AND THAT YOUR STAFF HAVE
DEMONSTRATED. THERE'S AN ALMOST
A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR NEED
FOR- INFRASTRUCTURE REPAIR
BASED ON THE- THE ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT IDENTIFIED
BY KITCHELL AND THEN ANOTHER
EIGHT SOMETHING- IDENTIFIED BY
THE CDC I'M SELF. SO THESE TO
INFRASTRUCTURE REPAIRS ARE
SORELY NEEDED BECAUSE THE
PRISONS ARE REALLY CRUMBLING-
SOME OF THEM. AND THEY MAKE
LIFE FOR MY CLIENTS THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN
INTOLERABLE IN SOME RESPECTS I
WANT TO READ TO YOU. A COUPLE
OF SENTENCES FROM A COURT ORDER
THAT WE RECENTLY OBTAINED LAST
YEAR ABOUT THE FACT THAT IN ONE
OF THE PRISONS THE ROOF WAS
FAILING- THE JUDGE WROTE IT IS
A SHAME THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AND REBUILD. HAVE A
LOT OF THE FACILITY A DINING
BEFORE ALL TO SEE JUST DISTRICT.
IT IN SPAIN IT'S A PICTURE OF A
CORRECTION. CIVIL WHEN I GO.
CAN SELL BOTH ITS LOCATION IN
THE NATION AND THE STATE OF
SUCH FINANCIAL ABUNDANCE AND
ADVANCE LEGAL STANDARDS FOR THE
HABITABILITY OF REAL PROPERTY
AND CLEANLINESS OF FOOD
SERVICES ESTABLISHMENTS AS YOU
REAL RECALL. THE FACT OF THAT
THE ROOF FAILED MEANT THAT-
THERE WERE- FECES FROM BIRDS
FALLING ON TO THE DINING HALL-
WATER DAMAGE WAS- POLLUTING OF
THE DINING HALL AND THE LIKE SO
THESE INFRASTRUCTURE REPAIRS-
NEED TO BE. PUT ON A VERY-
URGENT LEVEL MISTER DE AS HAS
BEEN GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO ALLOW
US TO- TO GO INSPECT THE
PRISONS. FROM THE KITCHEN
REPORT TO- PROVIDE OUR INPUT ON
WHAT A LIST OF PRIORITIES
SHOULD BE BUT I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO- MAKE THAT A
PRIORITY AS WELL AND BOTH OF. I
WOULD HOPE THAT SOME OF THE
FUNDS COULD BE PUT IN THE MAYOR
THE VISOR THE OR THE JUNE
BUDGET SO THAT THEY CAN GET
STARTED IN SOME OF THE MOST
CRITICAL PLACES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS. WE'LL HAVE TO YOU
HAVE WITH US WAS TO TING OR
COMPARED BUT EACH YEAR THANKS
FOR BEING HERE. WITH THE STONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY FOR BEING HERE AND
TAKING US THROUGH THE SAID I
THINK JUST THE- A FEW COMMENTS
AND THEN TRYING TO MAKE SURE
WERE HEADED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I THINK A COUPLE
YEARS AGO. THIS COMMITTEE WAS
WAS. ASKING FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
THAT COME FORWARD IS HOW HOW DO
WE START TO TALK ABOUT CLOSING
PRISONS. AND IF YOU ARE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN THEN WE
WOULD. I THINK EVERYBODY IS IT
SHOULD BE A LITTLE FEARFUL OF
US COMING UP WITH A PLAN SINCE
YOU'RE THE EXPERT SAID. IN HOW
IT GETS DONE. SO I'M A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNED AT AT THE
RELUCTANCE TO MOVE FORWARD
BECAUSE I THINK WE DO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE WE SPENT.
BUILDING CAPACITY IN SENDING
MORE MORE PEOPLE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE LAST NUMBER OF DECADES
THROUGH AND A NUMBER OF.
INITIATIVES THAT. HAVE NOT KEPT
OUR COMMUNITY SAFER BUT HAVE
JUST PUT MORE MORE PEOPLE TO
PRESENT IN WITHOUT THE
REHABILITATION. WHEN THEY COME
OUT THEY'RE ACTUALLY ADDING. TO
THE LACK OF SAFETY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE- HAVE NOT BEEN
WORKING WITH THE PUBLIC SAFETY
GOAL BUT JUST THIS NOTION OF.
LOCKING PEOPLE UP FOR THE SAKE
OF LACKEY BLACK. SO UNLESS
WE'RE ON A REAL TRAJECTORY. TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF BEDS IN
THERE AND REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. THAT WE ARE SENDING TO
PRESENT IT AND M. SINCE. THEN
WE'RE WE'RE CONSTANTLY BE
CHASING. MONEY AFTER- AFTER.
MONEY REALLY AND IN THESE
PROGRAMS I THINK FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THE INVESTMENTS.
IN INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO BE
PUSHING UP AGAINST THIS FEAR
THAT WHAT WE'RE REALLY DOING IS
FACILITATING. MAINTAINING THAT
SPACE MAINTAINING CERTAIN
CAPACITIES WITHOUT THAT GETTING
TO OUR REHABILITATIVE GOALS.
AND REALLY OUR PRISON REDUCTION
GOALS REDUCING THE THAT NUMBER
OF. OF PEOPLE WHO ARE HOUSE
ESPECIALLY HOUSED UNNECESSARILY
OR WERE COULD BE HELD IN
DIFFERENT PLACES. SO I THINK
THAT'S WHEN THINGS THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT HERE. AND
I'M VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE ABILITY TO COME FOR THE
PLANET I THINK THE PLAN ALSO IF
WE'RE GONNA DO THIS AMOUNT OF
WORK. IF YOU'RE GONNA DO THIS
ABOUT WORK BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THAT COULD BE DO A LOT OF IT. I
THINK THIS COULD ALSO SET UP
CRITERIA FOR LOOKING EVEN
FURTHER AHEAD OF HOW WE
CONTINUE TO KEEP MAIN GOALS IN
THE FOREFRONT. ALSO HOW WE
SCORE TO IDENTIFY ATTRIBUTES
MILESTONES CHANGES THAT
CONTINUE TO ALLOW FOR. CLOSING
MORE PRISONS AS THEIR- AS
BECOMES NECESSARY. AND ONE
THING THAT HAS COME UP SO THAT
THE LA- WAS TALKING ABOUT THE-
THE PUBLIC. CONTRACTED BEDS AND
I THINK IN YOUR STATEMENT. WE
WERE LOOKING TO CLOSE THOSE
PUBLIC CONTRACTED BUT STAY OUT.
SO I GUESS THERE'S A THERE'S A
BIT OF A DICHOTOMY THERE. GIVEN
THAT THOSE BEDS ARE CHEAPER.
AND. RESPECT ON. THAT THIS.
VERSE MAIN. SOME OF THE AND I'M
NOT WEIGHING IN WITH ANY
PARTICULAR. BENT ON WHICH IS
THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND BETTER.
THE DECISION MAKING IF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE. GOING TO BE CLOSING
PRISONS BUT MAINTAINING SOME
FLEXIBILITY. WHAT WITH THE
TRADE OFFS FOR THE PURPOSE
STANDPOINT TO MAKE THAT
DECISION. I THINK THE A ONE THE
ONE THE STATE GOT INTO THE
AGREEMENTS WITH. BEGINNING WITH
OUT OF STATE THE BEGINNING WITH
AND STATE BEDS CONTRACTING WITH
EITHER. PROFIT PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT. FOR COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES WHICH
ARE RUN BY LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED THOSE BEDS THE
OVERCROWDING SITUATION IN OUR
STATE PRISONS PROPER WITHIN THE
THIRTY FIVE INSTITUTIONS. AND
NOW READ A POINT TO WHERE WE
ARE DOWN O OUR LAST- BUT I
THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT THESE
INSTITUTIONS- WHERE THEY'RE AT
THESE FACILITIES FIRST OF ALL
HAVE TO THANK THEM FOR THE
SERVICE OF THE BEEN PROVIDING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN.
ALLOWING US PUT INMATES IN
THOSE BEDS THAT HAVE A VERY LOW
IF NO MEDICAL NEEDS VERY LOW TO
NO MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS INMATES
THAT ARE ON THE LOWER LEVEL OF
THE SECURITY SPECTRUM- SO THE
HOUSE IN THESE FACILITIES BUT
ONCE AT THE A AND THAT DOES
CONCERN ME WITH THESE
FACILITIES IS A- VIGIL THAT
WILL BE GOING HOME- SOONER THAN
OTHER. BECAUSE OF POINTS IN THE
SERVER AND I BELIEVE WITHIN THE
STATE PRISONS THEMSELVES OF
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
THIS BODY HERE- THROUGH THE
REHABILITATIVE MRS BROWN'S
APPLE. THAT SERVICE THAT GET IN
SOME PARTS DOESN'T IS BETTER
THAN WHAT THE AT THESE COMMIT
CORRECTION FOR. NOT TO SAY THAT
GOOD PARTNERS AND ME A NEED I
BELIEVE ARE ENTRY. AND SERVE
AND ACCESS TO THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE BETTER- WE HAVE- FACE TO
FACE COLLEGE LIKE I SAID
EARLIER WE HAVE BETTER
VOCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
TRAINING INSIDE OF OUR STATE
PRISONS WE HAVE THE ABILITY FOR
INMATES TO LEARN TRAITS THAT
ARE PRISON INDUSTRY AUTHORITY.
THAT THEY CANNOT GET AND THESE
COMMUNITY CORRECTION FACILITIES.
NOW WHAT. YOU KNOW ONCE MEANT
THAT I READ YOU KNOW THOUGHT
WILL. THE EFFORTS FOR THESE
OKAY. ARE BETTER THAN SOME OF
OUR STATE PRISONS. I HAVEN'T
SEEN- A REPORT FOR THAT I DON'T
YOU I WOULDN'T WANT TO
CHALLENGE THAT. BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT THE REASON WE HAVE
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THESE
FACILITIES- WE DO THEM BETTER
IN STATE PRISON- AND I WOULD
CHAMPION I WOULD. LOOKAT- TO
STICK WITH THE PLAN THAT'S BEEN
PUT FORTH BY THE GOVERNOR TO
BRING THEM DOWN- AND IN TURN I
KNOW THAT THE QUESTIONS WILL
WHICH ONE NEXT WHAT COMES NEXT
AND I'VE HAD. DISCUSSIONS WITH.
PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE HERE-
AND THEY'RE VERY GOOD
QUESTIONS. THE TWELVE PRISONERS
STUDY THAT WE- THAT WE SET
FORTH AND WITH- KITCHELL AS
MISTER SPECTER MENTIONED THE
CONTRACTOR WHO. DID THE STUDY
ON THE TWELVE OLDEST PRISONS.
WE HAVE A- WE WORKED WITH THEM
AND WE HAVE RECEIVED FINAL
REPORTS IN THE LAST TWELVE NOW
WE'RE THE NEXT STEP. IS TO WORK
WITH THE SAME CONTRACTOR TO- TO
SEEK A PRIORITIZATION- WITH
THEM. TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT.
WHAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
ARE IN THOSE LOCATIONS BASED ON
THE POPULATIONS THAT DO EXIST
WITH THEM. AND ALSO TO COME UP
WITH A PLAN IN REVIEWING
DEVELOP- AN ORDER IN WHICH THEY
WERE TO COME DOWN IN THE END IT
WILL BE A DISCUSSION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON WHICH ONES.
WHICH ORDER THEY WERE TO COME
DOWN CLOSE IN A PRISON IS NOT
AN EASY THING- WE HAVE SUB SUB
SETS A POPULATIONS THAT.
REQUIRE HIGH NEEDS- WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT- SOME OF THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE IN LOCATION
LIKE SAID BEFORE. WE DO HAVE A
HARD TIME RECRUITING. AND WOULD
HAVE A HARD TIME RETAINING
PEOPLE IN SOME PLACES AND THE
CONCERN. IF WE GET AHEAD OF A
TIME THAT WHEN WE'RE READY TO
ACTUALLY ANNOUNCE AN
INSTITUTION. IT WOULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE ABILITY
TO GET PEOPLE TO EITHER STAY AT
THE FACILITY OR TO RECRUIT TO
THAT FACILITY WITH SENATOR
COULD IMPACT OUR REHABILITATIVE
EFFORTS AT THAT FACILITY. RIGHT
AND THEN AND I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT WHICH IS WHY COMING WITH A
PLAN AND- AND RECOGNIZE THE
APPLICATIONS. I THINK YOUR
POINT IS WELL TAKEN ABOUT. IT'S
BILL TATE OF SERVICES THAT
NEEDS TO. REMAIN THE FOCUS AND
ACTUALLY BE AN ENHANCED FOCUS
AS WE MOVE THROUGH AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE IN SOME OF THE
CONTRACT THE PUBLIC CONTACT
FACILITIES WHICH WE NEED TO
GET. COMPLETELY OUT OF THE
BUSINESS OF DEALING WITH A
PRIVATE CONTRACTOR FACILITIES
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S THAT'S I
THINK LONG BEEN A OF A BIT OF A
STATE IN OUR SYSTEM AND HOW WE-
SHOULD BE CONTEMPLATING
OURSELVES. BUT WITH THOSE
FACILITIES. THOSE THOSE INMATES
THAT THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE. IN
CUSTODY THERE ON THAT CONTRACT
BASIS. PROBABLY ARE ONES THAT
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR. RELEASE WAR
PUBLIC SHOULD HAVE BEEN COULD
HAVE BEEN HELD T THE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND NOT NECESSARILY
BE. THE BURDEN BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S AS WE GET TO. A SYSTEM
WITH REDUCED CAPACITY AND
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING THERE THOSE ARE
SOMETIMES GOING TO BE THE MOST
DIFFICULT REALLY TO SERVE AND
SO I THINK THE PROGRAMMING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IT WILL
DEFINITELY NEED TO REFLECT
THAT- BUT IS WERE MAKING
DECISIONS AND TRY TO INVEST
AGAIN IN THESE FACILITIES AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MEETING
HELPING TO MEET YOUR
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AS AS SOME
OF THOSE FACILITIES ARE
CRUMBLING. I THINK WE NEED TO
BE MAKING SURE WHICH IS WHY
THIS COMMITTEES ASKED FOR. TO
THAT WE KNOW THAT WHAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN WITH
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES. THAT
WE'RE GETTING DATA ON HOW
EFFECTIVE THOSE SERVICES ARE
FOR. BIRD REDUCING RECIDIVISM.
THAT WE ARE KEEPING AN EYE ON
AND- WHERE THE POPULATION IS
AND WHAT THOSE SPECIAL NEEDS
ARE SO THAT AS WERE MAKING
THOSE DECISIONS ABOUT.
REHABILITATING INFRASTRUCTURE
OR MAKING SURE THAT THAT WE'VE
GOT PROGRAMMING REALLY ACROSS
THE SYSTEM THAT WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT ALL OF THOSE THOSE
IMPLICATIONS ARE. THAT'S WHY
COMING UP WITH A WITH STANDARDS
IN COMING UP WITH THE PLANNING
DOCUMENTS. AND REALLY BE ABLE
SAID THAT STANDARD AND IN
LOOKING TO PUT A CLOSE
WONDERFUL GOING CLOSE TO.
MOVING PEOPLE OUTOF THE
CONTRACT TO FACILITIES YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S ALL FINE BUT-
KEEPING IN MIND CRITERIA FOR
EVEN NEXT STEPS THE YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE KEEP LOOKING AT.
IMPROVING AND TESTING OUR GOALS
ALONG THAT WAY BECAUSE THEN
THAT MAKES IT A LOT EASIER FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE INVESTMENT IN THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT YOU NEED
VI<c.cyan> ROOFS VIçT OTHERS. SO</c>
THAT WE'RE NOT CONTINUE INTO TO
THROW GO GOOD MONEY AFTER JUST
CHASING MORE BEDS KEEPING
CAPACITIES UP WHEN I THINK WE
ALL HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE REDUCING THOSE
COULD THE ACTUAL NEED. FOR SOME
OF THESE FACILITIES OVER TIME
SO THAT'S WHY. I'D LIKE TO GET
THERE IN AND NOT. I THINK
THERE'S LESS. SPECULATION ABOUT
WHAT IF THIS BALLOT MEASURE
PASSES WITHOUT ABOUT MEASURE
PASSES I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
BE. SHY ABOUTPUTTING TOGETHER
AN AGGRESSIVE PLAN THINGS MAY
CHANGE LONGTIME BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF CONTROL WITHIN THE
SYSTEM. TO AFFECT THE
POPULATION AND WHO'S WHERE AND
WHY AND FOR PUSHING MORE FOR
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES AND I
WOULD HOPE WE COULD GET TO THE
POINT WHERE THIS COMMITTEE IS
LOOKING AT. EVEN POTENTIAL EVEN
THOUGH OUR GOAL IS TO REDUCE
THE OVERALL PRISON COST. IF
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ADDITIONAL
MONEY BECAUSE OF EFFECTIVE.
PROGRAMMING ASSISTING PEOPLE
WHO ARE INSIDE AND HELPING THEM
WITH WITH THEIR NEEDS SO THAT
WHEN THEY COME OUT WORK SEE
RECORD SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING
RECIDIVISM RATES I THINK THAT'S
THE VALUE. THAT WE ALL SHARE
HERE FOR AS LONG AS WE CAN.
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE COMMUNICATING IN IN
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT PLAN IS.
ANYONE ELSE MR LACKEY YOUR
QUESTION YEAH. JUST A JUST A
COUPLE COMMENTS- FIRST OF ALL
WE HAVE THIRTY FOUR PRISONS OR
SOMETHING CLOSE TO THAT RIGHT
CORRECT. FELT THE STATE AND
EACH ONE OF THOSE PRESENTS A
VERY UNIQUE- THEY HAVE UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENTS AS WELL AS
POPULATIONS. AND THAT THE
CRITERIA THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEEDS TO BE
ESTABLISHED ON DETERMINING. AND
EVERYBODY WOULD AGREE THAT-
REDUCING. THE PRISON POPULATION
IS A LAUDABLE GOAL AND SOME WE-
HOPE THAT THE TREND CONTINUES
TOWARD. BUT I WILL TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW THAT THERE ARE NUMBER
OF PRISONS THAT ARE AND VERY
VERY. A DEPLORABLE CONDITION-
I'M GOING TO MENTION ONE OF
THEM. PLEASANT VALLEY PRISON- I
HAPPEN TO KNOW. FOR A FACT THAT
WHEN IT RAINS. IT'S DISGUSTING
AND IT'S JUST UNIMAGINABLE THAT
THAT HAS NOT BEEN TAKING CARE
OF OVER THIS LONG PERIOD OF
TIME AND- I THINK THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT AND FUNDING-
BECAUSE THE CONDITION NOT ONLY
IMPACTS THE IN MAY BUT ALSO
EMPLOYEES AND I THINK THAT.
THIS PRESENT REDUCTION SHOULD
ALSO CONSIDER COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH THE PRISON EXISTS- WE
SHOULD ALSO AGREED TO CONSIDER
EMPLOYMENT IMPACTS- BY THE
EMPLOYEES AND HOW THEIR LIVES
ARE GOING TO BE IMPACTED BY
THIS DECISION MAKING- AND AS
WELL AS AS THE INMATE I MEAN AS
YOU WERE JUST INDICATING IT
DOESN'T LIKE WE HAVE A HIGH
VACANCY RATES IN AND OUR
PRISONS IF I UNDERSTOOD THERE
STILL POPULATION CONCERNS AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. MAYBE
EXACERBATING THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
AND I THINK THAT WE JUST NEED
TO BE CAUTIOUS. AND I THINK
THAT SOME OF THESE OTHER
CONCERNS. ARE DESERVING OF OUR
ATTENTION- AND I DON'T KNOW WHY
WE HAVEN'T DONE A BETTER JOB
OF. OF ADDRESSING SOME THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS BECAUSE
THEY'RE REALLY REALLY QUITE
STARK. AND IN MANY THE
CONDITION SOME WAY WORSE THAN
OTHERS BUT- THE ONE I JUST
MENTIONED AS- IT'S UNIMAGINABLE
THAT THAT SITUATION STILL
EXISTED SO. I WOULD JUST HOPE
THAT WOULD BE WE WOULD BE VERY
VERY CAUTIOUS AND THE WAY THAT
WE MOVE TOWARD THIS. VERY IT
LAUDABLE GOAL BUT NONETHELESS I
THINK WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON.
THE TOTAL PACKAGE AND NOT JUST
ONE ASPECT. APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER- AYE
AYE I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
PLEASANT VALLEY SITUATION I
KNOW THAT THE WARDEN
PERSONALLY- THE ROOF ISSUES AT
THAT INSTITUTIONS AND OTHERS
LIKE IT. THEY STEM FROM. I
THINK- RAMPING BACK UP FROM THE
LEAN TIMES DURING THE TOUGH
BUDGET YEARS- THAT CALIFORNIA
FACED- AND JUST THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT DID OCCUR IN.
IN ATTEMPTING TO TRY AND GET
FUNDING FOR THESE LOCATIONS AND
TOUGH YEARS WERE. WRONG PLAN
NOW THAT PLACE- PLEASANT VALLEY
IS FUNDED TO GET THOSE ROOFS
FIX THEIR- THEY ARE IN A BETTER
CONDITION BUT I DO HAVE OTHERS.
THAT WERE BUILT IN SIMILAR
TIMES- I HAVE SOME BURKE
PRISONS BUILT IN THE- EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS WITH RUSSO BETTER
CONDITION MAYBE IT'S A
DIFFERENT DESIGN OR DIFFERENT
TIMES WHO KNOWS. BUT I'M WELL
AWARE THAT THE IMPACT IT HAS ON
THE STAFF. IT'S TOUGH ENOUGH TO
GO TO WORK IN A PRISON JUST TO
DO THE THINGS THAT ARE. WITHIN
THE INTO CATIONS WHERE YOU HAVE.
FOR THEM. THIS IS. A TIMBER BUT
THE- WHAT THE FUNDING THAT WE
DID RECEIVE THE NINETY. IN PRE
A ON GOING. BY MONEY TO
CONTINUE WITH THOSE REPAIRS-
AND THE MONEY THAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR IN THIS BUDGET IS TO
GET HEAD. OF OTHERS OF THE
SITUATION SO WE DON'T HAVE A
PLEASANT VALLEY. NINE FIVE MAKE
ONE QUICK COMMENT SURE THAT. AS
I UNDERSTOOD- I'M NOT A
FINANCIAL PERSON SO BUT I'VE
READ IT FROM EITHER- MISS KIM'S
REPORTER THE LA- REPORT. THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY BUDGET OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING IS A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS
APPROXIMATELY. AND AS YOU JUST
HEARD. THE NEED IS AROUND
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS FOR AND
SO. I WOULD WELL HE'S- A
SECRETARY IS CORRECT THAT THEY
HAVE SOME MONEY- WE'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING THIS FOR MANY YEARS
I THINK THEY NEED A- MUCH
LARGER INFUSION AND I. HOPE THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WOULD SEE FIT
TO INCREASE THAT AMOUNT. ANY OF
THE COME QUESTIONS MISTER CHANG.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I THINK.
APPRECIATE BOTH OF MY
COLLEAGUE. MICHAEL THESE
COMMENTS AS WELL INSPECTORS
COMMENTS I THINK THE- THE
CHALLENGE WITH THE-
PRIORITIZATION- OF THE CAPITAL-
HAS BEEN THE FACT THAT WE-
HAVEN'T RECEIVED A
PRIORITIZATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. SO THAT'S BEEN VERY
CHALLENGING SO IT'S A IT'S I
THINK. YEAH MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
MOMMY. PALM DALES COMMENTS ARE
ARE RIGHT ON THE MONEY BET BUT
PART OF THE CHALLENGES IS
UNLESS WE HAVE A PLAN ON WHICH
FACILITIES GO FIRST AND WHICH
ONES ARE IN THE- WORST URBAN.
SIGNED OF DISREPAIR AS WELL AS
WHAT THE PRIORITIES IT'S SORT
OF HARD FOR US BECAUSE ALL WE
GET IS A LIST OF THE PEACE. AND
ALL WE CAN TAKE IS ABOUT I
THINK YOUR POINT IS VERY
EXTRAORDINARILY WILL TAKE THEM
YEAH NOT NOT TO TAKE ANYTHING
AWAY FROM YOUR COMMENT. ON SO
DOUBTS THE SECRETARY THE
OBVIOUS QUESTION TO WHICH ONE
NEXT AND WHEN WE KNOW. I THINK-
THAT ATTORNEY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND UNITED SPOKE AT LENGTH ON
THIS ON THIS ISSUE. AND OUR
DISCUSSIONS- THERE WELL TAKEN
AND THEY AREN'T THEY ARE
DISMISSED AT ALL BUT I KNOW THE
ONE QUESTION THAT CONTINUALLY
COMES UP IS WHICH ONE PLAN- AND
AS I SAID EARLIER. IT'S NOT AS
EASY- BUT I RECOGNIZE ASKING
FOR MONEY AND YOU APPROVING IT
JUST AS AN ATHLETE I RECKON
IT'S NOT EASY TO DO EITHER
BECAUSE I THINK ONE POINT THAT
I TOOK FROM MY CONVERSATIONS
WILL ASSIST TAKE THE- CRC
QUESTION. ABOUT WE'RE SEEKING
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO REPAIR
WALLS FLOORING SINKS AND FOR
MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION ARIA. BUT
THAT'S THE ONE THAT'S CURRENTLY
ALWAYS BEEN UP FOR DISCUSSION
AND YOU KNOW HAS HAS BEEN NOT
HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED THE ONE
THAT'LL CLOSE- I CAN TELL YOU
THAT WAS A SIX MILLION DOLLAR
REQUESTS BUT FOR NEW BUILDING
IT WOULD'VE BEEN A SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION WE
WOULDN'T REQUEST SEVENTY
MILLION BECAUSE OF THESE
FACTORS LIKE TO DISCUSS-
BECAUSE- IT COULD BE ONE. OR IT
COULD BE ONE OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY COULD. BUT I THINK WE
HAVE TO GET TO A POINT TO WERE
ONCE WE'RE BACK FROM THE IN
STATE COMMITTEE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. AS WE SEE THE
POPULATION STE- CONTINUE TO
DROP BUT THEN ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT WERE NOT A STATIC STATE
THINGS CAN HAPPEN. TO MISTER
SPECTER'S POINT. HE COULD FILE
A LAWSUIT AND COULD STORE SEND
A PROPER CRY BUT BUT BUT- HE-
MORE REASON. TO A PLAN. RIGHT I
MEAN YOU YOU YOU JUST HEARD ARE
MY CALLING ASKED VERY SPOKE
ABOUT A PARTICULAR. AND IN A
ROOF. COM I WISH I COULD I WISH
WE COULD ALL SAY WELL THAT.
THAT FACILITY RANKS NUMBER
THREE OR NUMBER THIRTY AND
THESE ARE THE REASONS WHY THAT
ROOF HASN'T BEEN. REPAIR RIGHT
I THINK THAT WOULD BE. READ
THAT THAT WOULD HAVE A LEAST
SOME RESERVE VERSES ON. WE'RE
WORKING ON OUR GUESS THAT
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE THAT WERE
WE'RE WORKING THAT THIS THE IS
ON. FOURTH YOUR HAVING. THIS
KIND HERE. YOUR ARE SET
SECRETARY HAVE IN THIS. TOPIC
HERE IN THAT BEEN THE CONTINUES
SPOTS I. DO GIVE YOU. TO SORT
OF WORK WAR AND ALL THINK ONLY
PERSON. LEFT TO ME IS A- AND I
JUST WANNA PLUG GOVERNOR. I
MAKING A VERY BRAVE.
ANNOUNCEMENT OF TALKING ABOUT A
PRISON CLOSURE THE BUDGET. IN
HIS BUDGET ANNOUNCED AND WE
THINK THAT'S GREAT AS I BY
COLLEGE SANTA CRUZ MENTION. THE
SYSTEM THAT BEEN ABOUT A
CHAMPION FOR FROM A NUMBER
YEARS AND COMMITTEE. BUT CLEAN
AUTO. KEEP HIS GONNA BE FRANKLY
LAST PATIENT AND I AM AND I
THINK THE CAN IS THE LACK CAN
ON THIS BUT ISSUE LAWS A MINUTE
PROPOSAL T CLOSE NORCO. AND IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THE TOP HAS EVEN
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THIS
DOES APPEAR THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENTS MOVED. ANYWHERE
NEAR THAT IS THAT FAIR TO SAY.
I THINK WE HAVE TO A DENTURE
QUESTION NO WE AREN'T ANY
CLOSER TO CLOSE THE NORCO WE'RE
NOT STEPS EVEN EVEN THOUGH THAT
WAS IN A MISTER STRICT VERSION
PROPOSAL. THAT BUT HASN'T I
WOULD SAY THAT EVERY IS TO THAT
WE HAVE OF THE THIRTY FOR
INSTITUTIONS THAT THAT WE ARE
NOT THE CONTRACTOR SO THAT CAL
CITY. THAT WE RECOGNIZE LIKE I
SAID IN THE BEGINNING THESE
ARE. THESE ARE PEOPLE IN THESE
LOCATIONS ABSOLUTE AND THE
FUNDING THAT I'M SEEKING. TO
IMPROVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WHETHER BE REUSS COUNTERS
HEALTH CARE MENTAL HEALTH
REHABILITATION SPACE. IT'S
BECAUSE I HAVE PEOPLE IN THERE.
TODAY AND WE ARE WAITING FOR
THE COMPLETION OF THE TWELVE
PRESENT STUDY SO I CAN. HAVE
THE- CHURCHILL'S ASSESSMENT OF
THE PRIORITIZATION. SO WE CAN
GO OVER WITH THEM THEN
EVENTUALLY WE CAN HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE IN OCTOBER.
STATED EARLIER EVEN BEYOND THE
TWELVE THE RE. THAT THERE'S
EIGHT EIGHT. EARLY IN THE OF
INSTRUCTION THE THEIR- SO EVEN
OUTSIDE THE TWELVE GOT A LOOK
AT OTHERS AND PINNACLE TWENTY
SIXTY SAID DOES US. THE
CRITERIA THAT WE DO LOOK AT AND
WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED FACTORY IN
INCOME TO THESE. NO NO I NOW
UNDERSTAND HAVE ENOUGH ACCOUNT.
OF AT THE TOLL PLANS I KNOW
WITH UPS AND BUT- MY FEEL IS
YOU. THIRTY FOUR THIS FACILITY
HE GOT FOUR VERY. WARDENS WHO.
YOU KNOW PER IF YOU IF YOU GOT
A MALL A CALL OR SEND A MORE
THE COULD. GO THROUGH ALL
VARIOUS I'D- THAT ARE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT. SO I GUESS I GUESS
I'M JUST TRYING UNDER. WHY THAT
HOW OCCURRED ALE WHY TO PER
HASN'T IT UPON ITSELF TO DO. A
MUCH CLEARER ASSESSMENT. AND
AGAIN LIKE I SAID YOU KNOW THE
WITH THE WORDS NO IT'S ON IN
THE U. YEAH I DON'T THINK
YOU'LL GET A HAVE TALKED ENOUGH
FOR A YOU KNOW ALL OF THEM.
THAT I'M THERE'S NOT ONE. IN
THERE FOR THAT THEY REALLY KNOW
ABOUT. SO IDEA THAT WE TO GO
HIGH SOME PALED MONEY. TO CAN
ASSESS OF WHAT FOUR OVER KNOWS.
TODAY SEEMS LOW BIT OUGHT. AND
SO HAS ACT. OCCURRED WE HAVE
COME OF WAR ON A BASS. AND I
CAN TELL YOU A WARDEN THE CHAMP
IN THEIR INSTITUTION HI THAT
THEY THEY THEY BELIEVE IN WHAT
THEY DO THEY NEED FUNDING TO
FIX THE THINGS THAT THEY
BELIEVE ARE IMPACTING. THE
INMATES IN THE STAFF AND- THE
WELL BEING OF EVERYONE THAT
WALKS IN THOSE GATES ON A DAILY
BASIS- THEY WOULD GIVE ME THEIR
PRIORITIZATION BUT IT WOULD BE
IN THE FORM OF BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO STAY. IN THE CURRENT
CATALOG OF CORRECTIONS BEYOND
FIVE YEARS WILBERFORCE THEM BUT
THAT'S- BUT THAT'S WHERE. YOUR
JOB AT. RIGHT I MEAN THERE JOB
IS TO. LET WHAT THEIR NEEDS IS
YOUR JOB IS TO. ASSESS MY MORE
GLOBAL POINT OF VIEW WHERE THE
STATE PARTIES ARE RIGHT I MEAN
DO YOU KNOW ALL YOU'RE ASKING
THEM IS I ASSUME. WHEN YOU'RE-
THE BCP'S AND YOU'VE IDENTIFIED
WHERE YOU'D LIKE THIS YEAR'S
BCP'S TO GO YOU GET THE LESS
FROM THE WARDENS THAT. IS THAT
FAIR WHAT DO THEY HAVE NOT HAVE
ANY INPUT IN THE WE GET WE GET
REQUESTS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
AND THEY ARE PUT IN TWO FOUR
FACILITIES MAINTENANCE THE
COMPUTER FACILITIES MAINTENANCE
DIVISION. FOR THE PRIORITIZE
THE RIGHT FACILITIES
MAINTENANCE DIVISION THAT COME
UP FROM THE WARDEN'S. AND HOW
DOES THE DEPARTMENT PRIORITIZE
THAT LAST. I THINK WE LOOK AT A
NUMBER ONE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY- AND THEN- WE TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT THE CURRENT IN
NEED IS FOR THAT PARTICULAR
INSTITUTION WHETHER IT BE A
HEALTH CARE FACILITY OR TO
DON'S CASE- MISTER SPECTER'S
ABOUT THE CHAU SITUATION. THAT
GOT BUMPED UP. SO THAT ONE HAD
TO GET FIXED SO IT'S ITEMS LIKE
THAT THERE'S SOME OF THEM ARE
EMERGENT. A SOE HOME LONG THIS
IS SHOWBIZ TODAY ALL FACT THAT
THE READY EMPLOY TO. WHICH
PROPOSALS RISE TO THE TOP OR
NOT WHAT WHY ISN'T THAT JUST
WHY DON'T YOU JUST PUT A PLAN
TOGETHER WITH THAT SAME CARD
HERE THAT YOU ALREADY
EMPLOYMENT. WE SOME REMEMBER WE
ARE. WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO. AT
WE GET AS DONE IT'S COME. BUT
AFTER WE GET THAT PART. DONE WE
WILL BE TO CAN. TO ROBUST DISK.
ABOUT WHICH ORDER THEY'LL DOWN
BY. THERE THERE IS NOTHING
STATIC ABOUT CORRECTIONS WHAT
WILL BE GOOD TO WILL BE GOOD
THE DAY. IN A MY THE COULD
CHANGE. THERE'S NOTHING STELLAR
ABOUT LIFE. A SO DOESN'T MEAN.
THAT I IF YOU CAME ME AS A I
DON'T HAVE A PLAN FOR MY LIFE
AGO WILL THEN WHERE YOU GO.
RIGHT IN QUITE FOR THE PART
WHERE TO PUT GO IT'S GREAT THAT
DEPARTMENT HAS A MAY ST. WHAT
IS THE PLAN TO EXECUTE. THE ON
THAT MISSION. I THINK AND SO
THE JUST ME FINISH SO GET AGAIN
COM. THE DEPARTMENT IS EVERY
DAY. PRIORITIZE AND- THE
CAPITAL NEEDS. OF THE THIRTY
FOUR FACILITIES SEPARATISM YEAH.
SO WHY IS THE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY PUTTING THAT INTO
PAPER. AND ACTUALLY
ARTICULATING THAT FOR OUR
VANTAGE POINT VALUES VANTAGE
POINT FOR THE PUBLIC SPANISH
POINT. WHY IS NOT PUBLIC
INFORMATION. I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THE ORDER OF
INSTITUTIONS OF THE GOING TO
COME DOWN. BUT ALSO ACROSS
VARIOUS THE COULD BUT BASS THE
COUNTRY THE CARTER STOP. THOU
PROCESS NOT PUBLIC CLINIC. IS
NOT PART COMING. YEAR WE THE
BOOK OF TOTAL REASONABLE
QUESTION WE GOT A- SAID HEY YOU
GOT A LEAKY WISER. MY VERY WE.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN ABLE TO
ANSWER WHY. ON WHY WE HAVEN'T
FIX THAT OR WHY WE'RE
REQUESTING FUN YOU KNOW WHY YOU
IN FOR THREE. WE ARE FIX THE
OFFICE OF YES. YES. WE GOT
FUNDED FOR REPAIRS HAVE BEEN
DONE TO ARE COMPLETED AND
OTHERS I HAVE TO CHECK WHERE
THEY ARE PURCHASE A BUT THEY
THEY MAY BE COMPLETE. WE ARE
REAP PLEASANT VALLEY. BUT I
WHAT WE ALSO KNOW FOR BECAUSE
OUR OTHER THE PROOF HAVEN'T
BEEN FIXED. THERE MAY ROOF
PROJECT RIGHT CURRENTLY PLACE
RIGHT AND THERE'S A- AT LEAST
FROM I COULDN'T REALLY ARE. WHY
THE IS. GOOD FOR SEDUCTIVE
EFFECTS. I IT'S BASED ON THE
NEED THAT COME WHAT HAVE FOUND
IS THE LEAN TIMES OF THE BUDGET
THAT WAS NO. PLAN TO YOU KNOW
SICK ON GOING FOR JUST REPAIR
THEY WERE ALWAYS OTHER EVEN
ISSUE THAT WERE COMING UP
RIPARIAN. BUT BUT I GUESS IS
THAT MEAN THAT IS. WHAT THOSE
GET SUBMITTED IS THAT. YOU HAVE
WE HAVE WITH SOME HELP OR
GUIDANCE. THE ANSWERS. LET YOU
LOOK OVER MUCH WHAT I DON'T I
DON'T I DON'T WHAT I APOLOGIZE
THE. AND JUSTICE. HI CLOSER TO.
IF I. HAVE A TWO YEAR ROLLOUT
SO THIS BUDGET INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR DESIGN AND THEN THE NEXT
YEAR INCLUDES MONEY FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND SO OVER THE
NEXT ABOUT TEN YEARS WE HAVE
THE SEVEN PHASES WERE WE'VE
ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED WHICH OF
THE RIVER PLACES WILL BE DONE
OVER THAT PERIOD OF TIME. AND
HOW DO YOU HOW DO THEY GET
PRIORITIZE. I'M AS THE
SECRETARY MENTIONED I THINK IT
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH KIND OF
THE STEP AT THE STATUS OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WHEN WE'VE
GOT ROOF WHERE WE'VE GOT LEAKY
BUT IT'S- THERE'S A PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCERN THOSE ARE
GENERALLY RISING TO THE TOP OF
THE LAST. BUT I WOULD ALSO
MENTION THAT THE- THE
DEPARTMENT HAS AN ONGOING BASS
LINE A SPECIAL REPAIR FUNDING
AND SO WHILE WE'VE GOT THIS
SEVEN YEAR ROLL OUT THERE'S
ALSO THE SPECIAL PERFORMANCE OF
WE'VE GOT OTHER ISSUES THAT
COME UP AT SOME OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS THAT MAY RATE RISE
TO THE LEVEL. RATHER THAN
WAITING FOR THE NEW BUDGET
PROCESS WE'VE GOT THAT ONGOING
BASICALLY FUNDING THE COULD
ALSO BE CONTRIBUTE TO THOSE
PERSONS ARTS TO THOSE REFER
PLACEMENTS ONE THICKER MY
FEELING IS LOOK WE HAVE THESE
HOME. SEPARATE FUNDS FOR A
MERGER FOR MANY OF THE
DEPARTMENTS FOR MANY OF THE
ISSUES AND CAL CAL FIRE COMES
TO MIND- IN TERMS OF SORT OF
APPROPRIATIONS WERE MONEY GETS
APPROPRIATE WE ARE OUT OF
SESSION BECAUSE OF EMERGENCIES
AND WE'VE- OBVIOUSLY HAD A
QUITE A FEW CAL FIRE
EMERGENCIES OVER THE LAST HERE-
WHAT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THE
DEPARTMENT COULD GET GREATER
FLEXIBILITY. AND FREEDOM IF. I
AM PUT FORWARD. THERE WAS A
METHOD. AND A PIRATE STATED TO
STATION PUT FORWARD. THAT WE
CAN ALL AGREE ON SO THEN. WE
WOULD HAVE TO TRY TO DECIPHER
ON THE PC PEAS ARE COMING
FORWARD AS WELL AS- HAVE TO NIT
PICK OVER EVERY SINGLE ITEM. OM
I THINK GOING BACK TO- I THINK
MIX MISTER SPECTER'S EARLIER
POINT AND ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY- THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN I
THINK RED ISN'T TOO- JUST WRITE
THE CHECK FOR- IN ALL THE
REPAIRS IS BECAUSE- WE KEEP
WAITING FOR. WHICH WHICH
POTENTIAL FACILITIES MAY BE UP
FOR CLOSURE SUCH I GUESS ONE
QUESTION IS INSTRUCTORS CAN YOU
GUARANTEE TO THE COMMITTEE THAT
YOU WON'T BE BRINGING FORWARD
ANY BCP'S OF ANY FACILITIES
THAT WILL BE PROPOSED FOR
CLOSURE BECAUSE THE LAST THING
WE'D LIKE TO DO IS PUT A NEW
ROOF ON A FACILITY THEY GO TEAR
DOWN TWO YEARS LATER OR HAVE A
NEW ROOF ON OFFICIALLY THAT
EMPTY AGAINST YOUR MEDICAL TERM
DOWN. I CANNOT I CANNOT GIVE I
CAN GIVE I CANNOT GUARANTEE
THAT TO THE COMMITTEE RIGHT SO
UNTIL YOU CAN GUARANTEE THAT
THAT IT'S MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO APPROPRIATE THESE
RESOURCES ON YEAH BECAUSE WHY
WHY WOULD I YOU KNOW GIVE YOU
MONEY TO FIX THE CAR AND THEN
SAID TO THE JUNK YARD THE NEXT
DAY. AND WE GOT LONG LONG LIST
OF CARS SOME THAT NEED TO BE
FIXED. I UNDERSTAND AND IT'S- I
JUST WANT TO LET THE COMMITTEE
KNOW THAT THERE IS NO INTENT TO
TRYING TO SAY HI. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CLOSE THE STATE PRISON
BECAUSE THAT IN THE END THAT'S
OUR GOAL. THAT IS ALL OF OUR
GOAL TO REHABILITATE TO LOWER
PRISON POPULATION TO MAKE SAFER
COMMUNITIES. BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE QUESTION OF CLOTHES IN A
PARTICULAR PRISON- THE IT'S NOT
AS EASY AS ONE WOULD THINK AND
WE ARE HAVING INTERNET
DISCUSSIONS THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO STAY WITHIN THE
SPIRIT OF TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN
AND- CREATING A LIST BASED ON
INFORMATION FROM THE TOLL PLAZA
STUDIES AND OTHERS. THAT WE
KNOW IT'S COMPLICATED EVEN MORE
REASON TO HAVE A PLAN. I DON'T
I DON'T THINK. YOU'VE HEARD
ANYBODY UP HERE SAYING THAT A
STOCK COMPANY ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVE IT'S COMPLICATED BUT-
EVEN MORE REASON TO HAVE
CRITERIA AND EVEN MORE REASON
TO HAVE A PLAN. NO ONE'S
ARGUING THE EIGHTEEN MONTH TIME
FRAME. BUT I THINK WHAT WE WHAT
WE ARE ARGUING AS WE DON'T WANT
TO BE WASTING. VERY PRECIOUS
TAXPAYER RESOURCES. BECAUSE YOU
CHANGE YOUR MIND. SOLD THAT'S
NOT OKAY MOVIE WE HAVE MANY
OTHER THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
SPEND THE MONEY WE HAVE HE A
PRESCHOOL FACILITY GOT
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES WE
HAVE. ON RECREATIONAL CELLS
WITH HEALTH FACILITIES THIS IS
NOT THE ONLY GAME IN THIS
BUDGET SO SUGGESTS JUST SWITCH
THE TOPIC HAS COME BACK TO
FINANCE FOR SECOND THAT'S ONE
TO CLARIFY WHAT ON. FINANCE IT
ON THE ABILITY XIN WHICH IS.
YOU MENTION THAT THE INCREASES
SPENDING WITH ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION TO ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION OF CAP OVER
WHAT TIME FRAME THE WAS. SO
EVER EXPECT TO SPEND FIVE OR
FIFTY THREE MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I COMPARED TO THREE
MILLION IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THIRTEEN. OKAY THE END CAN. CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE- RECIDIVISM
RATE- IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE ON WARES TODAY I DON'T
HAVE INFORMATION ON ME BUT I
CAN. SO YOU SO YOU INCREASE
SPENDING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ORDER PROPOSED TO DO IT
IN ABOUT TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
WHAT WHAT IMPROVEMENTS IN
RECIDIVISM HAVE OCCURRED TO
THAT SPEND ANOTHER ARMY BUT
CAN DEFINITELY GET ABOUT BACK
TO WHEN I. WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE
SECRETARY HAD PARTY NO THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
WORKING. I WOULD SAY THAT THE
MOST RECENT RECIDIVISM NUMBERS
ARE THERE THEY STAYED PRETTY
MUCH THE SAME FORTY SIX FOUR
SIX POINT OF THINGS FOR SIX
POINT FOUR. I THINK THAT'S IT
FOR SIX THIRSTING FOR CUT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION UNDER SAID
ABOUT AND THAT THEY COULD THESE
REPORT NUMBERS FROM THREE YEARS
PRIOR. TO THAT SO WE'RE DEALING
WITH THOSE NUMBERS AS AS A
COURT COMES OUT WE ARE. STILL
WAITING TO SEE WHAT THESE
INVESTMENTS CUT PAN OUT IN THE
NEXT COHORTOF RECIDIVISM
NUMBERS BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING
THREE YEARS PASS AS WE DEVELOP
THE COHORT NUMBERS FOR
RECIDIVISM YES WHAT WE'RE HERE
LAST YEAR WE HAD THIS. SUMMER
CONVERSATION AROUND RECIDIVISM
SO- WHAT THE QUESTIONS I HAD
ASKED IS SORT OF. HOW TO TRACK
THE PROGRESS BY IN MAY SO
WANTED TO JUST HEAR AFTER
TWELVE MONTHS. HAVE MADE ANY
PROGRESS ON BEING ABLE TO TRACK
THE PROGRESS PER IN MAY. IF WE
LOOK AT THE GAINS OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN.
INMATES WHO HAVE EARNED CREDITS
BASED ON THESE EXPANDED REHAB
OPPORTUNITIES THAT'S THE ANSWER
MY QUESTION THE QUESTION IS
VERY SPECIFIC HAVE YOU. MADE
GAINS IN TRACKING THE PROGRESS
BY IMAGE IF I'M AN INMATE. AND
I AM TAKING COURSES. HAVE YOU
MAY PROGRESS IN TRACKING THEM
TRACKING THAT INFORMATION
BECAUSE A YEAR AGO. WE GOT A
SOME RESPONSE TO THE FACILITIES
QUESTION WHICH IS WE WERE
WORKING ON SO I JUST WENT
THROUGH YOUR DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS WE
HAVE. INCREASED OUR TRACKING
AND ARE OUT COMES ON IT AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS COMMITTEE WHAT
MEANS OF THE LAST COMMITTEE
THAT WE'RE IN FRONT OF WE DID
WE DIDN'T HAVE A- A ROBUST
TRACKING SYSTEM WE HAVE NOW
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE DIVISION
OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS TO
SHOW THE GAINS IN THE VARIOUS
INVESTMENTS IN REHABILITATION
SO WAS I SAID HE PULLED UP MY
RECORD WILL THIS. BEFORE JOHN
DOES RECORD. I THINK IT DEPENDS
ON WHAT YOU KNOW WHERE THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS IN THERE WHAT
WHAT WILL TAKE FROM WHAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT IT BEFORE YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY INFORMATION AS TO WHAT
INFORMATION WILL POP UP WHEN
YOU SAY I THINK WE'RE IN FOR
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
REHABILITATIVE CASE PLANTS OF
THE CORRECTIONAL COUNSELING
SERVICE PLUGIN INMATES INTO
THESE PROGRAMS THAT THAT
OTHERWISE WOULDN'T BEEN ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE BECAUSE OF THE
PRISON REDUCTIONS. WERE ABLE TO
GET INTO PROGRAMS- AND IT MORE
AND MORE RAPID MANNER- ANY BUT
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
IS THE POINT IN TIME GAME FOR
EVERY SINGLE INMATE I WOULD SAY
THAT- THE GAINS THAT WE'RE
SEEING THAT IN THE INSTITUTIONS
INMATES ARE RECEIVING MORE
PROGRAM AND THEY HAVE IN THE
PAST THERE IN COLLEGES AND
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS THEY ARE.
WELL I'M NOT I'M NOT GONNA
ARGUE THAT BUT- WISHES CAN YOU
PROVE IT. CAN YOU PROVE. I
BELIEVE WE CAN HELP THROUGH
THESE RECIDIVISM REPORT NUMBERS
WHICH I CAN HAVE A REAL BILL
RIGHT RIGHT PROGRAMS ALL ABOARD
THE CALL ME ALL OF YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF
MY COLLEAGUES AND WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT LICENSES AND
DIFFERENT DEGREES AND WE KIND
OF TAKE DIFFERENT COURSES TO
ACCOMPLISH DIFFERENT THINGS.
YOU KNOW. MY COLLEAGUE FROM-
PONDO HE KEPT YOU CAN DO
BETTER- HOW THE PATROL OFFICER
WITHOUT. YOU KNOW
ACCOMPLISHMENT TAKING THEIR
CERTAIN COURSES HAVE INSTRUMENT
OF TRAINING. SO IS THAT BEING
TRACKED ON AN INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
BY HIM. WE TRACK LITERACY
GAINES WE TRASK COLLEGE
COMPLETIONS WE TRACK VOCATIONAL
COMPLETIONS WE TRACK. OF COURSE
WE TRACK PARTICIPATION REBUILT
IN A PROGRAMS WHICH LEAD TO
MORE INCREASE CREDITS EARNED BY
INMATES WE TRACKED THE
MILESTONE COMPLETIONS- THAT-
GAIN BY INMATES WHO MASTERY OF
THE SUBJECT SOLD SO LIMITED YES
BOX SO YOU TRACK WHEN SOMEONE
PASSES A MILESTONE. YOU HAVE NO
IDEA WHERE THEY ARE TO
ACHIEVING THE MOUSE DOES NOT
FOR CHARACTERIZATION I GUESS I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT WHAT
THAT MORE JUST LIKE JUST LIKE
IF YOU GO T COLLEGE. DO YOU
KNOW FOR LACK OF A BETTER WORD
YOU THINK SO GRADUATE SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW WHEN SOMEONE'S
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL YOU DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY CLASSES THERE
SHORTCOMING CLASSES IT TAKE. TO
GET TO. I THINK I JUST WANTED
TO SEND IT IS THAT CORRECT OR
NOT. I MEAN SOME OF. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE IT'S JUST WE DON'T
HAVE IT ON HAND WHAT I'M-
SELECT YOUR GREAT PLAINS
TRACKING WHAT IT MEANS COME AND
WEATHER AT. YOUR WEATHER AT IN
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA LEVELS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE LITERACY RATES.
ALL RIGHT SIDE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE I THINK WHAT'S BEEN
SAYS WE JUST DON'T HAVE IT ON
HAND I CAN DEMONSTRATE IT WITH
YOU. HELLO I WASN'T ASKING FOR
BUT THE YOU HAD LIKE FROM THE
COMMITTEE I'M ASKING IF YOU HAD
IT A ALL AND- YET YOU HAVE.
YES AND- DOES THAT. HELP DRIVE
THE ASSIGNMENTS. FOR BY IN MAY.
YES BECAUSE BECAUSE WHAT I'VE
WHAT I'VE VISITED. I'VE ONLY
VISITED FEW OF THE FACILITIES
SO AGAIN THIS IS NOT A- BY THE
WAY THE SIDE. EFFECTS STUDY OF
IT. COME IT SEEMED RATHER THAN
PEOPLE BEING ASSIGNED COURSES
OR CLASSES ALONG A MORE LINEAR
APPROACH TO TELL YOU WHAT IT OR
ARE SOMEWHAT LINEAR APPROACH
WHICH IS HOW YOU WOULD ASSUME
THIS WOULD GO. IT WAS JUST SORT
OF LIKE. YOU KNOW FOR LACK OF
BETTER WORDS YOU KOW LIKE I'M
VISITING SO PEOPLE GOT. WHAT'S
GOT PUT IN CHAIRS THE PARTS OF
YOUR GREAT LAKES DEVELOPING
THIS PRINTER PROGRAMMING FOR
COLLEGE FOR JUNIOR COLLEGE AND
YOU'LL SEE IT. THE PROPOSAL
LATER THIS YEAR IN A COUPLE
WEEKS FOR HIGHER ED ON THERE
YOU'RE GOING TO GREAT LENGTHS
TO COORDINATE THE SUCH A
PROGRAM IS MAKING SURE THAT IN
THE SECOND MAN HAVE. THE BASIC
SKILLS TO DO THOSE COLLEGES-
WORKING WITH THE JUNIOR
COLLEGES THERE ARE PROVIDING.
NINE DEGREES GET THEM OUT I
NOTEBOOK GLOBAL LEVEL ALL THIS
IS. OCCURRING WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HIS DETAILS
MATTER. RIGHT CAN I THINK A
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE I
MEAN THAT THAT THIS IS THIS IS
THE BEST WAY TO PUT RIGHT INTO
THE JOB IS I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT SALINAS VALLEY BECAUSE
WE HAD THE ON. INSPECTOR
GENERAL HERE LAST YEAR THE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS AGO WE HAD A VERY
YOU KNOW- A LIVELY HEARING
BASED ON THAT FACILITY- AND WHY
YOU WOULD BUY YOU WOULD LOOK AT
A GLOBAL LEVEL AND SAY OH
SALINAS ALWAYS GOT A SHOP CLASS
SOARING AUTO BODY CLASS AND
THEN THE UP FRONT. I THINK IT
WAS. HVAC CLASS THEN YOU HAVE A
LAW LIBRARY WHEN YOU HAVE A
COMPUTER CLASS AND YOU HAVE A-
LIFE SKILLS CLASS. THAT THERE
WERE WASN'T. THE CASE BECAUSE
NOT. EVERY INMATE AT THE
FACILITY COULD TAKE. THOSE
CLASSES BECAUSE EACH OF THOSE
CLASSROOMS WITH SEGMENTED BY
YARD. AND THERE ARE FOUR
DIFFERENT YARDS AT THAT.
FACILITY IS THE ONLY REALLY
ONLY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
THAT I THINK ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND INMATES COULD. ACCESS
THE AUTO BODY SHOPS OF MORE
GLOBAL PRISON LEVEL YOU CHECKED
THE BOX. BUT ONLY 25% OF THE
FACILITY PEOPLE THE FACILITY
CAN ACTUALLY. TAKE THAT CLASS.
I THINK AND A- AND YOUR TOWARD
AND WE SPOKE BRIEFLY ABOUT AND
I THINK ONE OF THE I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS FROM A ONE DAY
VISIT IT DOESN'T PAINT THE
GREATER PICTURE OF WHAT IT
TAKES TO ASSIGN INMATES TO
VARIOUS JOBS PROGRAMS BASED ON
WHATEVER FACILITY THAT THEY
LIVE ON BECAUSE NOT ALL
FACILITIES. HOUSE NOR CAN MEET
THE NEEDS OF THAT THE WHOLE
FACILITY THE FACILITY YOU
VISITED IT'S NOT A SHARED
SHARED FACILITY MEANING ONE IN
MACON ACCESS ALL THE PROGRAMS
IN THAT WHOLE PRISON THERE ARE
THOSE TYPES OF PRISONS SALINAS
IS THAT IS NOT ONE OF THEM- I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE THOUGHT
THAT IF AN INMATE ON A YARD-
COULD FILL A VACANCY ON DELTA
FACILITY. I THINK JUST. FOR
CONVERSATION YEAH THAT'S AN
EASY THING TO DO BUT THERE ARE
CONCERNS THAT THEY MADE ON THAT
FACILITY CANNOT FOR HIS OWN
SAFETY OR THE SAFETY OF OTHERS
PROGRAM ON THAT FACILITY NO
THAT'S THE ONLY THAT'S QUESTION
AUDITED THE QUESTION IS IF THE
INMATES AND DELTA YARD HAVE A
LAW LIBRARY HOW COME BUT THEY
WANT ACCESS TO THE AUTOBODY
SHOP HOW CAN THEY CAN GET
ACCESS TO THE ABACHA. I'M I'M
NOT UNDER. WHO YOU HAD AUTO
BODY SHOP SALINE YARD. YOU KNOW
OUR YARD HEY. AND YOU GOT
INMATES ON YARD THAT WANNA ACT.
THE COURSES ON YOUR DAY THEY
CAN'T DO THAT THE FACILITY. IF
THERE ARE. FOR WHATEVER
CUSTODIAL NEED ARE CONCERNED
THAT EXISTS THAT HE CANNOT BE
PLACED IN THAT FACILITY THEIR
HOUSE THEIR BASE FOR VARIOUS
REASONS THERE WILL COME A DAY
AND I HOPE THE DAY WILL COME TO
WHERE I CAN. HOUSE ALL INMATES
TOGETHER. AND MAKING SURE SAME
FACILITIES AND THE THERE'S NO
RISK OF VIOLENCE OR- FLOOR NO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT EVEN
INTERMINGLING YOUR YOUR MISSED
THE POINT AGAIN AGAIN THE THAT
THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU HAVE.
INDIVIDUAL CLASSROOMS TIED TO
INDIVIDUAL YARDS CORRECT. IN
SEOUL ONLY 25% OF THE INMATES
COULD ACTUALLY TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF THOSE CLASSROOMS 25% OF THE
INMATES OF THE WHOLE OF THE
WHOLE OF THE WHOLE PRISON YEAH
THE WHOLE PRISON SO FROM
FACILITIES EIGHT A D. ONLY 25%
CAN ACCESS EIGHT YARDS. AT AND
FOR THAT REASON I SPOKE ABOUT
EARLIER THAT THERE ARE VARIOUS
REASONS WHY THEY CANNOT AT THAT
FACILITY IS NOT A SHARED.
SHARED USE FACILITY. NO I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I THINK
THAT THE CHALLENGES IS THAT. ON.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR THAT THE
AGAIN AND AGAIN I'M I'M LOOKING
A BIG PROPONENT OF
REHABILITATION DONE CORRECTLY I
THINK WHAT'S CONCERNING IS
GOING BACK TO THE DISCUSSION WE
JUST HAD A CAPITAL IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT. COM DOESN'T HAVE A
SYSTEMIC WAY. OF BEING ABLE TO
TRACK THE PROGRESS SO EVEN IF
THE AGAIN EVEN F THE
RECIDIVIST NUMBERS I YOU KNOW
ARE.ARE THE SAME OR EVEN LET'S
SAY HIGHER. BUT IF YOU COULD
SEE ROGRESS BY INDIVIDUAL YOU
WOULD HOPE. THAT AT SOME POINT
THOSE NUMBERS WOULD GO DOWN. I
THINK THE CHALLENGE IS RIGHT
NOW THOSE RECIDIVISM NUMB BUT
THAT THAT THAT TRACKING.
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL THAT YOU WOULD EXPECT
WITH THAT SIZABLE INVESTMENT.
SO I MEAN IT'S UP TO MAYBE IT'S
JUST YOU KNOW WE NEED TO GET
TOGETHER AND UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
BEING TRACKED AND WHAT'S NOT
BUT BASED ON AGAIN YOU KNOW
I'VE ONLY VISITED A COUPLE OUR
OUR BUDGET TEAM IS VISITED A
LOT MORE ON. THERE IS THE-
THERE IS NOT THE CORRELATION
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE FROM
THE INCREASE IN SPENDING TO THE
LEVEL OF TRACKING TO THE LEVEL
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT OFFERING
MORE COURSES I THINK YOU ARE
FROM OF COURSE. I DON'T THINK
IT'S BECAUSE THE COURSES. OUR
BAD CONNECTION I DIED I HAVE I
HAVE A REASON TO BELIEVE I WAS
GIVE THAT WITHOUT THE PROGRAM
IS GOOD. OR ARE RELATIVELY
SPEAKING YOU KNOW GOOD GOOD
IT'S- THAT THE PROGRAMMING IS
ADEQUATE TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL. I
THINK. A MAJOR PROBLEM IS.
WHETHER OR NOT THE INMATES ARE
BEING PLACED IN THE RIGHT
CLASSES AT THE RIGHT TIME. IN
THE RIGHT ORDER TO ACHIEVE
THEIR AND CALL. I BELIEVE THE
PLANE BEING PLACE AT THE RIGHT
TIME AT THE RIGHT PLACE ON THE
RIGHT FACILITY. WHAT WAS I'M
SORRY WHAT WHAT IS THAT BUT IS
THAT WHAT THAT MEANS IS TO
ORIGINAL POINT TO WHAT WHY
CAN'T AN INMATE ON FACILITY A
ACCESS THE CLASSROOM FACILITY
DE. THE END MADE UP OCILLA GA
HE IS ABLE TO ACCESS THE
PROGRAMS ASSIGNED TO HIM AT
THAT RIGHT TIME BASED ON HIS
REHABILITATIVE NEEDS. ON THAT
FACILITY GOD. IN SO IF THAT.
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE BEING OFFERED AT THAT
PARTICULAR YARD THEY JUST
AREN'T GETTING THEM. I THINK AT
SOME POINT WE SEEK TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER ALTERNATIVE
HOUSING FOR HIM THAT MEET HIS
NEED. THAT CAN'T LET THAT'S
COMMENSURATE WITH HIS MENTAL
HEALTH MEDICAL. SECURITY
CONCERNS. MAYBE AT ANOTHER
FACILITY WE HAVE OVER WRITTEN.
THOUSANDS OF INMATES DOWN. TO
LEVELS SO THEY CAN GAIN ACCESS
TO THESE PROGRAMS WE HAVE BEGAN
WORKING OUTSIDE OF OUR NORMAL
OPERATION SECURITY CONCERNS OF
AN INMATE HASN'T RECEIVED
DISPONER HISTORY BUT YET IT'S
STILL TRADITIONALLY HIGHER
LEVEL. WE WILL HOUSE AMONG THE
FACILITY FOR HIS NEEDS CAN BE
MET. SO WE HAVE GONE BEYOND TO
THINK DIFFERENTLY TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERN THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT
THINGS LIKE HOW COME HE CAN'T
ACCESS A PROGRAM ON ANOTHER
YARD. WE HAVE TO HOUSE MONEY
FACILITY THAT'S COMMENSURATE
WITH HIS CURRENT NEEDS. AS TO
NOT. PUT IN THIS SITUATION WAS
BAD FOR HIM OR HER. RIGHT BUILT
THAT IS THE ULTIMATE PRIORITY
AGAIN IS THE. THE PROTECTION OF
HARM THIS INDIVIDUAL MAY OR MAY
NOT COSTS RELATIVE TO THE
PERSON'S REHABILITATION. I
THINK THAT'S ALL OF OUR CONCERN
I THINK THIS SHOULD BE
EVERYONE'S CONCERN YEAH. BUT
BUT I GUESS. MY CONCERN ABOUT
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM IS WE'VE
INVESTED TWO HUNDRED MORE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE- PREVIOUS GOVERNOR
THIS GOVERNOR HAVE KIND OF
STEPPED UP AND ON THEIR PART
AND SAID HEY YOU GOT BASICALLY
ALMOST DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
REHABILITATION FUNDING THAT.
THAT TOM YOU HAD FROM BEFORE.
IN THERE THE REASON YOU KNOW
I'M I'M SORT OF THE LABOR THIS
POINT IS THIS TO ME IS THAT THE
KEY TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
DEPARTMENT. IS WHETHER THE
DEPARTMENT REALLY HOUSE AND
ABILITY TO IMPROVE SOME
INDIVIDUALS LIKE. RIGHT IS HE
YOUR ARE YOU JUST WERE HOUSING
SOME INDIVIDUAL IN TAKEN TIME
OFF THEIR LIFE OR IT IS
ACTUALLY THE GOAL TO. IMPROVE
THEIR LIFE. THAT WHEN THEY COME
FOR HOWEVER LONG THEY COME FOR
THAT THEIR LIFE IS IMPROVED.
AND I KNOW IT SOUNDS- PERHAPS
POLLYANNA SHORT LITTLE BASS
PROVISIONAL- BUT ALL SPEND IT A
DIFFERENT WAY I MEAN I WILL SAY
YOU'VE YOU'VE RECEIVED. THE
MONEY TO NOW IMPROVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS BLOCKS. ADD. YOUR
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT THE
DEPARTMENTS. BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
DOING SO. I BELIEVE THE
INVESTMENTS BY THIS LEGISLATURE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
IMPROVED THE LIVES OF INMATES I
BELIEVE THEY HAVE A HAS
IMPROVED THE OUTLOOK ON. WHAT
THE POST INCARCERATION LOOKS
LIKE. THAT HAS IMPROVE THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES IN FRONT OF
PAROLE BOARDS- WE HAVE SEEN
GRANTS AND PAROLES LABORAL
DATES LIKE WE VIA BUT I NEVER
WITNESSES A- AS A PRISON YOU
KNOW RANK AND FILE PERSON. AND
THAT'S TO THESE INVESTMENTS.
I'VE SEEN THE GAINES AND- THE
POST RELEASE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION PARTNERS
THAT ARE OUT THERE. TO THE
POINT TO WERE INMATES- FORMALLY
INCARCERATED TO HAVE LIVED
EXPERIENCE COME BACK. TO POUR
BACK INTO THE IN MY POPULATIONS
BECAUSE OF THESE INVESTMENTS SO
YES I DO SEE A BENEFIT OF IT
AND I DO BELIEVE WE'RE TRACKING
IT WELL AND I KNOW THEY'LL BE
SOME FOLLOW UP WITH YOU I'M
SURE OR THIS COMMITTEE. SORRY
FINANCE YEAH I JUST WANNA SAY-
THE INVESTMENTS OF IT MADE HAVE
KINDA LET THE FOUNDATION FOR
SOME PRETTY INNOVATIVE THINGS
YOU'LL SEE NEXT FEW WEEKS
PROPOSALS ARE FOR EXAMPLE-
DEPARTMENTS ESTABLISHING THE
YOUNG OFFENDER FREE
REHABILITATIVE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. WHICH CLUSTERS YOUNG
OFFENDERS TOGETHER TO HAVE
MORE- DEDICATE TREATMENT FOR
TRAUMA- GONNA SEE A
MODERNIZATION OF AQABA
TECHNOLOGY TO GET THE MORE
ACCESS TO DOING HOMEWORK
STUDIES- ALSO ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT CONTINUES THE
FRAME THE GROUNDWORK HAS BEEN
LAID HAVING THEM GIVEN ACCESS
TO YOUR CALL JUSTIN HOPPING
HIGHER AT GET BASHERS AGREES I
MEAN I WAS. WITHOUT WHAT'S BEEN
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE THE
PAST THAT YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
THESE IN A VEHICLES COMING
FORWARD- SO LOOKING FOR THE
DEFINITELY YOU CAN SEE THOSE
AND PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEE
AND- YES ONE MORE BOTTOM BUT I
THINK YOU KNOW YOU'VE- GONE TO
GREAT LENGTHS OF A THAT
FOUNDATION THAT. THE FRUITS
LABOR WILL BE COMING FOR NOW
WITH THESE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE GONNA HAVE YOU
MENTIONED MORE YOUR THE END OF
THOSE NEEDS AND CAN HELP THEM
REBUILD EIGHT REHABILITATE FAST.
AND YOU KNOW LEADER OF RECESSES.
OF RECIDIVISM. THANK THANK YOU
BYE THAT CAN I THINK. HOME AT
THE- I DON'T ARE WITH THIS.
THAT WHAT YOU'VE WITNESS HAS A
I'M SURE THE KERR. I THINK
WE'RE LOOKING FOR. IS NOT
CHEST. HOME GREAT INDIVIDUAL
STORES BUT WERE LOOKING FOR IS
MUCH LARGER WHOLESALE CHANGE.
AND I THINK WHAT WE WANT TO SEE
IS- IN A MUCH MORE SYSTEMIC
CHANGE AND I THINK PART OF THAT
IS AGAIN MAKING SURE WE HAVE
THE DATA. TO UNDERSTAND YOU
KNOW HOW PEOPLE ARE MOVING
ALONG THEIR OWN PERSONAL
INDIVIDUAL ROAD MAPS KNOWING
THAT EVERYBODY'S ROAD MAPS
COULD BE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY BASED ON THEIR
SENTENCE BASED ON THE KIND OF
SILLY- BUT- ALSO. YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE THAT THE CLASS SAYS
THAT- YOU KNOW ARE BEING ARE
BEING MATCHED YOU KNOW MUCH OF
THE YOU KNOW OKAY AND CAN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT PERCENTAGE IT
IS RIGHT BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE GETTING OUT OF THE
PRIVATE THIS PRINT THE BEST AS
WELL SOME OF THESE PRIVATE
PRISON CONTRACTORS ARE. THE
BIGGEST CONTRACTORS BEHIND
THESE WILL BE ABILITY ASIAN
PROGRAMS THAT. CORRECT BUT SOME
OF THE BIGGEST THING I MEAN
THEY'RE THEY'RE PART OF BUT NOT
THE BIGGEST NOW IS IT AT THE
BECAUSE I JUST THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE LIKE I SAID WE BUT BUT
WE WE'VE MADE A DECISION THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET OUT OF
CONTRACTING WITH THESE FOLKS
BECAUSE WE DON'T OUR OUR
INTERESTS AND THEY'RE JUST
DON'T REALLY ALONG. CORRECT
RIGHT BECAUSE THEIR INTEREST
ARE ALIGNED. BY KEEPING PEOPLE
IN AS LONG AS POSSIBLE SO THEY
KEEP MAKING MONEY. STE SO WHICH
IS NOT A WHICH IS NOT ANY OF
OUR PRIORS I THINK I THINK WE
ALL SHARE THE SAME SAME.
ALIGNMENT YEAH THESE ARE SO THE
SAME THE FOCUS. WHO HAVE
CONTRACTS FOR THESE QUORUM
COURT REHABILITATION. PROGRAM
RELEASE YES POST RIDLEY
CIRCUMSPECT YES HOW ONE METHOD
WHICH MIGHT- ALLEVIATE YOUR
CONCERNS I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
DO THIS BUT IF YOU HAVE A
PERFORMANCE- GOALS IN THE
CONTRACT. AND THEY DON'T MEET
THEM- THERE COULD BE SOME
PENALTY OR- SOME. OF OTHER
INCENTIVES FOR THEM TO MEET
THEM I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
POINT I THINK THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR I'M LOOKING FOR.
PERFORMANCE METRICS DATA. ON A
MORE. GLOBAL LEVEL- YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT YOU KNOW HOW WHAT
PERCENT ARE INDIVIDUALS ON TO
REACHING THEIR GOALS ARE I
DON'T THINK WERE. I'M NOT WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS VERY.
CHALLENGING THE WORK IS VERY
VERY HARD BUT THE DEAL WITH ALL
THE PLAN ON CAPITOL. WE GET
OTHERS LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
DATA LACKING. AND YOU KNOW WHAT
PROGRESS INMATES ARE MAKING. I
BELIEVE THE DATA DOES EXIST WE
DON'T HAVE IT HERE WITH ALL
STATE WOULDN'T BUT THAT'S WHAT
I LOVE AYE I WILL RETRACT THAT
STATEMENT CAN YOU KNOW FOR.
TOTAL WE MEET AND GO THROUGH
THAT DATA. OKAY THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU MISTER CHANG-
WANNA THANK ALL F YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ARE I THINK MOST OF
THE QUESTIONS ARE PROBABLY HAVE
NOT YET BEEN ANSWERED- BUT I DO
WANT TO. EMPHASIZE THAT- YEAH
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT AND
A DEVELOPING A PLAN. OF FOR AT
LEAST THREE FOUR YEARS. AND I
AM OPTIMISTIC HOPEFULLY THAT WE
WILL SEE A PLAN. THAT WILL COME
FORTH IT WOULD BE EASIER FOR.
YOU n
HAVE POINTED OUT TO DEVELOP
PLAN- I'M NOT SURE IF THE PLAN
COULD ACTUALLY BE DEVELOPED
FROM THOSE WHO RUN PRISONS IF
THEIR PRIMARY OBJECTIVE IS TO
ALWAYS DEFEND THE PRESIDENT. OF
IT- AND THAT. IT JUST IN THE
CONVERSATION THERE THAT THEY'RE
GONNA DO THAT PUT THEIR BEST
FOOT FORWARD TO KEEP THEIR
PRISON. DOES IS NOT GOING TO
HELP US BASICALLY ARRIVE AT
THAT CONCLUSION SO I THINK AS A
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
MAKE A DECISION FAIRLY SOON. AS
TO WHAT WE THINK THE PROCESS
SHOULD BE AND MAYBE IT'S NOT
THAT PROCESS WHICH WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE. OF COMING FORWARD
TO SAY THAT- WE'VE BEEN ASKING
FOR THE LONGEST AND AS A RESULT
WE HAVE HELD BACK. SOMETIMES
RESOURCES AND BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT TO FIND OURSELVES
REHABILITATING SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE HAVE IT HAVE PLANS TO.
TO BASICALLY CLOSE DOWN FAIRLY
SOON OR THERE OR THE COSTA
REHABILITATION IS SO GREAT.
THAT IT'S NOT WORTH IT BECAUSE
WE WOULD HAVE TO DO ENTIRELY.
WE HEAR WHAT MY BILL ANOTHER
ONE BECAUSE OF THE INVITE. IS
AND A HOST OF OTHER THINGS THAT
THESE PRISONS HAVE SO WE REALLY
NEED TO HAVE A VERY GOOD
ASSESSMENT OF OUR SYSTEM- WITH
REGARDS TO WHAT ITS NEEDS ARE.
AND THEN AS A WELL AS WELL AS
WHAT KIND OF SERVICES ARE BEING
OFFERED. AS A LOOK AT THE
REPORT I SEE THAT YOU HAVE ALL
THE INITIALS THE EACH SEASON
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON. SO I
YOU KNOW I ASK MYSELF A
QUESTION- JUST A AS AN AVERAGE
A BALLPARK FIGURE HOW MANY
PEOPLE DO WE HOW MANY PRISONS
DO WE NEED THAT OFFER THESE
KINDS OF SERVICES. KNOWING THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE SOMEWHAT
FLEXIBLE. SO YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO GET IT TO THE ACTUAL DOWN TO
THE VERY END MADE IN TERMS OF
USE. BUT IF WE KNEW THAT THERE
WAS A NEED FOR EX NUMBER OF
ALWAYS SEES WHATEVER THAT IS I
WAS LOOKING AT ONE OF THE
NUMBERS THAT THAT. OPEN HOUSE
SOMETHING SOMETHING OPEN.
OUTPATIENT YEAH YEAH ALL YOUR
ALL YOUR SYMBOLS YOU'VE GOT IT
YOU'VE GOT IT. YOU GOT YOUR
YOUR YOUR LEDGER THAT IT TELLS
ME ALL THE VARIOUS KINDS OF
SERVICES. THAT ARE THAT ARE
PROVIDED AT AT A PARTICULAR
PRESENT. SO I'M SAYING TO
MYSELF OKAY IF I JUST AND I'M
NOT THE ONE THAT'S INFORMED IF
I'M JUST LOOKING AT BECAUSE
THEY WOULD DO I NEED FIVE OF
THOSE LITTLE ANY THREE OF THEM.
TWENTY TWO OF THEM. YOU KNOW DO
THEY WORK WELL WITH THIS SYSTEM
VERSES THAT SYSTEM. MY
ASSUMPTION IS YOU KNOW THAT ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE
OFFICE KNOWS THAT. SO IF WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT NEEDS AND
MAKING SURE THAT. IF WE IF WE
WERE TO CLOSE A PRISON. OF THAT
THOSE NEEDS ARE STILL BEING
MET- IT WOULD SEEM TO BE
LOGICAL THAT THAT WOULD BE A
PART OF THE CONVERSATION THAT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE EXT NUMBER
SERVICES EXT OF A MENTAL HEALTH
BILLS BATES WHATEVER IT IS. SO
THAT AS WELL AS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT- OF GETTING RID OF SOME
OF THE OLDER PRISONS THE ONES
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
REPAIR ANYMORE- THAT THAT WOULD
BE. A VERY BOLD SOMETHING THAT
WE WOULD LOOK AT. OF CLOSING
THE PRISON AS A NO WILL BE A
VERY DIFFICULT TASK BECAUSE
EVERYBODY I'VE BEEN HAD MEMBERS
ALREADY. TELL ME THEY WANT THE
PRISONS IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD.
OF THEY WANT TO- TO KEEP THEM.
THERE THAT NOT THE MAJOR ONES
BUT THE ONES THAT THEY'RE
USING. IN THE SMALLER CITIES
THAT THAT HANDLE THE OVERFLOW
THAT DON'T PROVIDE.
REHABILITATIVE KIND OF SERVICES
WE THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE.
THAT'S GONNA BE A MAJOR ISSUE
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME MEMBERS.
WAY DR ECONOMY OF THAT
COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW WE AT THAT
THAT IS A CONSIDERATION BUT IT
CAN'T BE THE MAJOR
CONSIDERATION IN TERMS OF WHAT
WHAT FACILITIES WE KEEP. UP
BECAUSE EVERY. ALL EVERY PRISON
HAS A POPULATION. OF PEOPLE
THAT THEY EMPLOY. AT AND THEY
FOR. INTO THE ECON OF THEIR
COMMUNITY. SO YOU KNOW WE CAN'T
SAY OKAY WE CAN'T BECAUSE IN
THAT CASE WE SHUT NOTHING DOWN.
AND I KNOW THAT'S A BIG ISSUE
EVEN WITH THE MILITARY WHEN
THEY'VE CLOSED DOWN THINGS AS
ALWAYS ALL THESE OTHER THINGS.
THAT ARE TAKING IN
CONSIDERATION YET. US SOMETIMES
FOR ECONOMIC REASONS WE HAVE TO
DO THAT. SO I YOU KNOW I SEWER
COMMITTEE WILL WILL HAVE. A
MORE IN DEPTH DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHAT WE PLAN TO DO IN TERMS OF
MOVING FORWARD. BECAUSE WE
CAN'T KEEP ASKING THE SAME
QUESTIONS OVER AND OVER- WE'RE
GONNA LOOK AT THE
REHABILITATION ISSUE THATWAS
ONE FROM LAST YEAR- ENDS AND WE
MAY ASK FOR. A MORE IN DEPTH
REPORT ON THAT I WAS TALKING TO
STAFF ABOUT THAT BECAUSE- OF
ONCE AGAIN THAT WAS ONE OF THE
MAJOR ISSUES THAT. WE WERE
PUTTING PEOPLE IN CLASS WE HAVE
THE NUMBERS THE DATA. BUT THEY
WANT IN THIS ONCE THEY NEEDED.
I AM SO YOU KNOW IF YOU TAKING
THE FOURTH. SOMETHING AND YOU
DON'T KNOW THE FIRST LEVEL.
IT'S GONNA BE DIFFICULT FOR YOU
TO APPRECIATE THE FOURTH LEVEL-
AND SO THAT SEEMS TO BE A- ONE
OF THE THINGS IS THERE AND HOW
WOULD HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT-
MAYBE EVERY PRISON DOESN'T
OFFER ALL OF THE SAME. KIND OF
SERVICES OR EITHER YOU LOOK YOU
YOU LOOK AT THAT. THERE'S A LOT
OF TIMES WE MOVED FROM. LEVEL
FOR THIS SECURITY TO THREE TO
TWO TO ONE SO MAYBE THERE'S
SOME. SOME STRATEGY THAT NEEDS
TO BE UTILIZED- IN TERMS OF
INTRODUCING MATERIAL AT ONE
LEVEL. AND MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO-
FOR THEM TO BE. MOVED AS THEY
PROGRESS IN AT DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF THEIR- INCARCERATION. BUT
CLEARLY THIS IS A QUESTION THAT
WE KEEP ASKING. OVER AND OVER.
A WHERE THE PLAN WAS A PLAN WAS
A PLAN. I DON'T THINK WE WANT
TO STRIDE PLAN. OF MOST OF US
CARE. BUT I DON'T THINK YOU
WANT ME TO BECAUSE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND ALL THE SYMBOLS BUT
ACT MAKE UP- SO. I DON'T THINK
YOU WANT THAT TO HAPPEN. ALL
WELL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT I.
THINK IT A MUCH MORE JUST A
MEDIC WAY. KNOWING THAT EIGHTY
PLAN WE PUT TOGETHER MAY HAVE
TO BE A- CHANGED. IT OFFICE
SOME UPTAKE OR THERE'S SOME
GREAT DECLINE SOMEWHERE. WE
HAVE TO MAKE THAT ADJUSTMENT
WITH TO MAKE THAT CHANGE- BUT
IT BUT TO CONTINUE TO. EXIST
WITHOUT A CLEAR. ALL MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO FUND
THINGS AND TO. JUSTIFY WHAT
WE'RE DOING. AND MEET THE NEEDS
OF THOSE WHO INCARCERATED AT
THE SAME TIME. OKAY UNDERSTOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WANT TO
GO TO OUR NEXT ITEM. WHICH IS
OUR UPDATE OF US STAFF%
COMPLAINT PROCESS. AND WILL
BEGIN OF CALIFORNIA YOU MISTER
OF A SECRETARY YES. I GUESS SO
WE I DIDN'T DRAFT UPPER RIGHT
UP LARGE TALKING POINTS BUT
POPULATION BUT I WILL SAY THAT
SINCE SOME THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN VENTURING AND WE ARE IN
THE- FINALIZE LANGUAGE AS IT
RELATES TO THE ALLEGATION
ENQUIRING MANAGEMENT SECTION.
IT IS A NEW TO NEW. POLICY THAT
WE ARE DRAFTING AND PROPOSING
TO SUBMIT ON THE NIGHT OF MONTH
FOR SUBMITTAL TO THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW BY THE FIRST
AVAILABLE TO IMPLEMENT THIS NEW
DRAFT LANGUAGE THAT- I BELIEVE
IT REVAMPS HOW WE AS A
DEPARTMENT HANDLE ALLEGATION
INQUIRE RES- IN OUR PRISONS AND
COMPLAINTS FROM INMATES- THE
ORIGINAL CONCERN DEVELOPED FROM
AN OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
VISIT TO SALINAS VALLEY STATE
PRISON. AND HOW THE INSTITUTION
WAS HANDLING THEIR STAFF
COMPLAINTS WHAT WHAT WE FOUND
AFTER DISCUSSION AS A REPORT
WAS DRAFTED. WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT THE CONCERN WERE PRISON
STAFF THEMSELVES WERE ASSIGNED
TO ANSWER ALLEGATION INQUIRE
RES AND WRITE REPORTS- TO THE
HIRING AUTHORITY OR THE WARDEN-
ON INVESTIGATIONS THAT WERE-
DONE THAT WERE. BEING ALLEGE
INSIDE THAT SAME PRISON WHAT-
WHAT THE CONCERN AND RIGHTLY SO
NOW WE CHANGE THAT THE
REGULATIONS HERE WAS THAT STAFF
MEMBERS ARE FORCED TO WRITE
REPORTS ON FELLOW STAFF MEMBERS
WOULD BE LIKE. THE PRESSURE WAS
TOO INTENSE THE OBJECTIVITY WAS
NOT THERE SO A DECISION WAS
MADE TO THESE REGULATIONS AND
EVEN BEFORE. TO MOVE THAT OUT
OF THE PRISON SYSTEM- IT. THAT
OUT OF THE PRISON SYSTEM. THANK
YOU DOCTOR. WHAT TESTS WERE.
OUT OF THE PRISON ITSELF AND
THE THROUGH THIS SECTION
ALLEGATION MANAGEMENT- SECTION
WHICH NOW IT DOESN'T EXIST
UNDER THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS WHICH- THE ENTITY
THAT OVERSEES THE PRISON THE
THIRTY FIVE INSTITUTIONS. SO
THAT. OUT OF THE OFFICE OF-
OFFICE- OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS AT NOW SITS UNDER A
SEPARATE UNDERSECRETARY. WHICH
IS UNDER THE- ANOTHER DIRECTOR
WHICH IS OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON
AND THEY ARE IN CHARGE OF THE
OVERSIGHT OF THIS POLICY AND
THIS CHANGE AND HOW WE HANDLE
APPEALS AND GRIEVANCES. SO WHAT
THAT DOES IT GIVES A MORE
OBJECTIVE REVIEW OF COMPLAINTS
SUBMITTED BY INMATES- AND THAT
GIVES- WARDENS A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING FROM- FROM
OUTSIDE ENTITIES. A WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF THEM VERSUS WHAT'S
BEEN GENERATED BY THE
INSTITUTION AND ALSO-
SOLIDIFIES A LANGUAGE THAT
THERE WILL BE NO REPRISALS BY
ANYBODY FOR FILING A COMPLAINT-
IT ALSO. ELIMINATES THE
SCREENING PROCESS- WHAT WE USED
TO SCREEN OUT IN THE OLD DAYS
BEFORE THIS POLICY- LISTINGS
ARE SREENED OUT- IT ALSO
MANDATES THAT THE STAFF THAT
ARE GOING TO BE CONDUCTING
MEANS ALLEGATION INQUIRE REESE
ARE TRAINED BY SEE POST- WHICH
IS A CHANGE FROM THE PAST AND I
THINK IT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
TRAINED IN A MORE PROFESSIONAL
WAY. ONE THAT IT'S MORE
INDUSTRY STAND- BUT THEN ALSO-
IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR COMPLAINTS
IF THEY DO COME BACK AND THERE
IS A DISAGREEMENT ON WHAT IS
ACCEPTED AS THE STUFF COMPLAINT
OR ALLEGATION INQUIRE IT
THERE'S ALSO BACKSTOPS. WITHIN
THIS REGULATION THAT ALLOW THE-
THE NEW DIRECTOR OVER THE
OVERSIGHT TO REFERRED THIS OVER
TO THE DIRECTOR OF THE HEALTH
INSTITUTIONS TO HAVEN'T SECOND
LOOK WHAT AWARD AS CHOI. NOT TO
THE RIVER SOME FAIR. SO IN THE
I BELIEVE REMOVING THE PILLS
FOR. THE PRESIDENT. IS A IS A
GOOD CHANGE. MOVING INTO AN
OUTSIDE ENTITY IS A GOOD
CHANGE- REMOVING THE REVIEW
PROCESS OUTSIDE OF THE PRISON-
IS A GOOD CHANGE- I KNOW. THIS
WORK- WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSION
WITH WITH MANY PEOPLE OVER TO
INCLUDE MISTER SPECTER THAT
NUMBER IS CONVERSATION MISTER
SPECTER AND I KNOW. HE DOESN'T
AGREE WITH SOME ASPECTS OF THIS
IN THE FINAL CONCLUSION OF IT
BUT I BELIEVE WE HAVE MOVED-
MOVE THIS POLICY IN AN AREA TO
WHERE I BELIEVE WE WILL SEE
GAINES. I KNOW THERE IS A
REQUESTED AN ASSET THAT THIS
NEW POLICY AND REGULATION TAKE
ON MORE THAN IT WAS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED. TO INCLUDE USES OF
FORCE ALL USES OF FORCE TO
INCLUDE PRISON RAPE ELIMINATION
TO ALMOST MOVED ALL ENQUIRIES
UNDER THIS NEW SECTION. BUT I
NEED DO NEED TO BE CLEAR THAT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS A WRITTEN
THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT IT WAS
ORIGINALLY INTENDED FOR IT WAS
INTENDED. TO HAVE A MORE
TRANSPARENT OR OBJECTIVE REVIEW
OF INMATE ALLEGATION INQUIRE.
WHAT WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT.
I THINK THIS CHANGES THE
DYNAMIC. OF HOW THE PRISONS ARE
DEALING WITH ISSUES I THINK IT
HAS OTHERS OTHER EYES ON THEM
THE TRADITIONAL WEREN'T THERE
AND IN THE END I BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE GONNA. THE ISSUES ARE
BEING ADDRESSED IN HERE- CHANGE
HOW INMATES WILL RECEIVE
INFORMATION AND THEIR THEIR
COMPLAINTS- REMEDIED. I THINK
IT'S IN IT'S IN A BETTER PLACE
NOW. NOW I KNOW MISTER SPECTER
AND I WE DISAGREE ON SOME
SECTIONS OF THIS BUT- AS A
WHOLE. MOM I THINK THAT WERE OR
BETTER OFF WITH THIS THIS NEW
POLICY. FINANCE HELLO AS YOU
RECALL WE HAD RAISED SOME
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
WHEN IT CAME THROUGH LAST AS
BRING AND WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
REITERATE BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
NEW COMMENTS AT THIS TIME AND
WE DO PLAN TO LOOK AT THE
REGULATIONS WHEN THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU
TO EVALUATE THIS IN THE BROADER
CONTEXT OF WHAT'S HAPPENED IN
THIS DEPARTMENT FOR THE LAST
FEW DECADES- I WILL GO BACK
THAT LONG BUT IF YOU'LL JUST
BEAR WITH ME FOR A FEW MINUTES.
FIRST OF ALL I LIKE TO START
WITH THE PROPOSITION ABOUT YOUR
EMPHASIS IN THE LAST PART OF
THE HEARING ON REHABILITATION.
I THINK THAT'S EVERYBODY'S GOAL
OF BUT I THINK- MISTER DE AS
WILL AGREE WITH ME THAT YOU
CAN'T DO REHABILITATION IN A
PLACE. WHERE PEOPLE DON'T FEEL
SAFE. AND IN MANY PLACES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
ESPECIALLY OVER TIME. PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED DON'T FEEL
SAFE AND IN SOME CASES THE
STAFF DON'T FEEL SAFE EITHER-
SO- MY COMMENTS ARE DEVOTED TO
MAKING THE BEST. USE OF THIS
APPEALS PROCESS SO THAT UP. THE
STAFF MISCONDUCT IS MINIMIZED
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE SO IN A
FULLY FUNCTIONING SYSTEM- WHERE
YOU HAVE GOOD STAFF ACCOUNT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR STAFF OF THE
PROBLEMS A WITH STAFF
MISCONDUCT ARE IDENTIFIED BY
THE DEPARTMENT AND THEY
RESOLVED BY THE DEPARTMENT SO
THAT THEY DON'T GET OUT OF HAND
AND ARE YOU HAVE SAFELY RUNNING
PRISONS. ARE UNFORTUNATELY OF
THAT HASN'T BEEN THE CASE
THROUGH THE HISTORY OF THIS
DEPARTMENT AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS AND- I THINK IT'S
FAIR FAIR TO SAY THAT- FOR THE
REASONS I WILL ARTICULATE IN
THE SECOND THAT THE STAFF
COUNTY ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM IN
THE DEPARTMENT. IS BROKEN HAS
BEEN BROKEN FOR DECADES-
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A ESSENTIALLY
ONE SCANDAL AFTER ANOTHER IT
JUST DEPENDS ON WHETHER WE OR
SOME OTHER ENTITY LIKE THE
OFFICE OF INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
BEEN ABLE TO DISCOVER IT. SO AS
YOU MAY AS SOME OF YOU MAY
REMEMBER AND THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES- QUIRK AND WAS
INVOLVED WITH A GLADIATOR
FIGHTS WHICH WAS SET UP BY
CORRECTIONAL STAFF. THEN IN THE
NINETIES THERE WAS PELICAN BAY
WHERE THE COURT FOUND THAT
THERE WAS AN INTENTIONAL
PATTERN OF EXCESSIVE FORCE USED
FOR ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES AS
PUNISHMENT. THAT WAS CURED
THROUGH A LEGAL ACTION AND A
COURT ORDER IN THE MADRID CASE
MORE RECENTLY- HIGH DESERT- WE
ON COVERED THROUGH OUR
MONITORING OF PEOPLE WITH THIS
BILL THE ADA CASE ARMSTRONG-
THAT WE DID A OVER WE
DISCOVERED A PATTERN AND
PRACTICE OF. COME STAFF
MISCONDUCT RANGING FROM-
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE TO
RACIALLY OF. RACIAL COMMENTS
LATE RACIAL SLURS TO TREATING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND A
AND A AT A DISCRIMINATORY
MANNER- AND- THEN THIS OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL DD A
REPORT ABOUT THAT AND FOUND-
FOUND EXACTLY WHAT WE HAD. A
LEADS TO OCCURRED AS HAPPENED-
IN EVEN MORE RECENTLY IN
SALINAS VALLEY STATE PRISON-
THERE WAS A PATTERN OF EXCESS
OF MISCONDUCT- IT WASN'T CURED
BY ANY NONE OF THESE WERE CURED
OR EVEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT TO OUR KNOWLEDGE-
AND- THE- OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL WHEN THEY LOOKED AT
SALINAS VALLEY FOUND THAT THE
WHOLE IN QUERY PROCESS INTO
WHETHER THERE IS STAFF
MISCONDUCT. WAS COMPLETELY
BROKEN BECAUSE THE STAFF
FOREIGN TRAINED THEY WERE
OFTEN- THE COLLEAGUES OF A
SOME. OTHER STAFF MEMBERS WHO
WERE DURING THE REVIEW. OF THE
WARDENS WEREN'T REFERRING
MATTERS UP THE CHAIN TO THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS IN
AN APPROPRIATE WAY AND- THE
SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY LACKED
INDEPENDENCE- FROM THE
INSTITUTION. SO NOW- I DON'T
KNOW WITH WITH THE NEW IT BUT
MY COLLEAGUES- AND MY CO
COUNSEL FILED A MOTION-
RECENTLY JUST ON FRIDAY ABOUT
RICHARD DAY DONOVAN- FACILITY
WHICH THEY ALLEGED- PERVASIVE
STAFF MISCONDUCT AGAINST PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WHO ARE
HOUSED IN THAT FACILITY. AND I
JUST LIKE TO KIND OF. READ YOU.
A COUPLE OF SENTENCES FROM THAT
MOTION WHICH SAYS BASED WHICH
ARE BASED O A FIFTIES SOME ODD
DECLARATION SIGNED BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED SAYS THAT
OFFICERS OF THROWING PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES OUT OF
WHEELCHAIRS THEY'RE PUNCHING
DEAF PEOPLE WHEN THEY CANNOT
HEAR SPOKEN ORDERS THEY'RE
BEATING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO REQUEST HELP
CARRYING HEAVY PACKAGES THEIR
CLOSING CELL DOORS ON PEOPLE
WHO USE WALKERS AND WHEELCHAIRS
AND ATTACKING SUICIDAL PEOPLE
WHEN THEY ASK FOR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE WITNESSES REPORT AT LEAST
ONE AND POSSIBLY TWO INSTANCES
WHERE STAFF USE FORCE IN A WAY
THAT CONTRIBUTED TO THE DEATHS
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED.
THAT SOME OF THOSE
DECLARATIONS- WERE REVIEWED AND
OTHER INFORMATIONAL REVIEWED BY
THE FORMER SECRETARY OF THE
WASHINGTON STATE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS WHO IS AN EX
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED EXPERT ON
PRISON AND HE SAID TO DATE CGC
APPEARS TO BE INCAPABLE OF
CHANGING THE STAFF CULTURE
DESPITE HAVING A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION FROM CREDIBLE
SOURCES ABOUT THE NATURE AND
DEPTH OF THE PROBLEMS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. THE OMBUDSMAN FOR
THE US SECRETARY OF CORRECTIONS
OF ROAD IN EMAIL TO- THE
DIRECTOR OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS.
AND IT'S WORTH QUOTING- AT A
LITTLE IN LENGTH SHE SAID- HE
SAID WHAT WE HEARD WAS
OVERWHELMING ACCUSATIONS OF
ABUSE BY THE OFFICERS AND
SERGEANTS WITH SERGEANTS AND
LIEUTENANTS LOOKING IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION I HAVE NEVER
HEARD ACCUSATIONS LIKE THIS IN
ALL MY YEARS I WOULD STRONGLY
SUGGEST PLACING A STRIKE TEAM
ON THIS YARD IMMEDIATELY. MANY
OF THE INMATES HAVE EXPRESSED
FEAR WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THEM
TOMORROW WHEN THE TEAM IS NOT
THERE THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
SITUATION AND NEEDS IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION IF THERE IS ANY MEANS
OF INSTALLING CAMERAS
IMMEDIATELY I WAS STRONGLY
SUGGESTED AT LEAST IN THE BLIND
SPOTS IN THE BACK DOOR OF THE
GYM. A REVIEW OF THE APPEAL
PROCESS RULE VIOLATION REPORTS
AND STAFF COMPLAINTS OR FAT
YARD ALSO NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE THAT'S
THAT'S NOT US THAT'S THE
OMBUDSMAN. LATER OF THE CHIEF
FONG BIRDS AND WROTE THERE HAS
BEEN LITTLE TO NO PROGRESS IN
SEPTEMBER I AM NOT TYPICALLY AN
ALARMIST BUT AGAIN I HAVE NEVER
HEARD SUCH DISREPAIR
HOPELESSNESS AND FEAR FROM
INMATES. AND I HAVE BEEN ON
QUITE A FEW OF THESE TEAMS TO
REVIEW AN INTERVIEW INMATES THE
CI W. TOUR RESULTS DON'T COME
CLOSE TO THIS AND SEE AYE W.
WAS VERY BAD. SO IN ADDITION TO
THAT- WE HAVE THE SITUATION AT
THE- SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SACRAMENTO STATE PRISON- AT
FOLSOM. WHERE THEY WERE NINE
SUICIDES IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THAT'S AN ASTRONOMICAL
RATE OF SUICIDES OFPER
POPULATION. THERE WERE THREE
HOMICIDES- AND WE'VE JUST
LEARNED. FROM A TOUR LAST WEEK
THAT. NOT ONLY INMATES ARE
FEARFUL OF GET OF RECALL OF
LEAVING THEIR CELLS TO GET
HEALTH CARE BUT THE DOCTORS
NURSES AND OTHER CLINICIANS ARE
SCARED TO PROVIDE THE CARE-
BECAUSE OF THEIR FEAR OF
VIOLENCE. SO WHAT YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS THAT CDC ARE
REALLY HAS NO WORKING SYSTEM TO
IDENTIFY THESE PROBLEMS THAT
SYSTEM IS US THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE MY COLLEAGUES AND ROADS
IN BE GALVANIC GROUND FILLED IN
AND THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
SOME EXTENT IF I WERE TO
CHARACTERIZE THE SITUATION IN
THE MOST GLOBAL TERMS I WOULD
pACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM- IS NOT
INDEPENDENT. OF THE
INSTITUTIONS AND- IT'S NOT
COMPLETELY CENTRALIZED THAT
STILL- WORKING AT THE
INSTITUTIONS. SO LAST YEAR- YOU
ALL AS THE LEGISLATURE- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- APPROPRIATED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO HIRE-
SPECIALLY TRAINED INVESTIGATORS
IN THOSE THE ONES THAT MISSED
STE MISTER DE AS WAS REFERRING
TO. AND WE APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH AND WE APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
INCLUDING MISTER DE AS
SUPPORTED THAT IN ORDER TO
START TO AMELIORATE SOME OF
THESE PROBLEMS- AND THOSE
INVESTIGATORS WILL BE A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE
THEY WILL LIKE MISTER DATA SAID
THERE WILL GET ENHANCE
TRAINING- AND THEY WORK FOR THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
WHICH YOU KNOW HAS BEEN. IT'S
THAT HAVE THEIR THEIR ABILITY
TO PROPERLY INVESTIGATE CASES
IN THE PRISONS HASN'T BEEN
QUESTION. SOME MIGHT THE PLACE
I START FROM IS YOU HAVE A
WORKING PART OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS. WHAT YOU NEED
TO DO IS PUT MORE OF THE CASES
INTO THAT DEPARTMENT FOR THEM
TO INVESTIGATE BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN TRAINED AS INVESTIGATORS
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND THEY CAN THANK YOU YOU CAN
HAVE THE RIGHT. MORE ACCURATE
AND RELIABLE RESULTS. SO BUT IN
THE NEW REGULATIONS DRAFT
REGULATIONS THAT MISTER DE AS
REFERRED TO- SOME OF THEM ARE
POSITIVE CHANGES THAT- HE
MENTIONED A NUMBER OF THEM AND
I FULLY SUPPORT THEM BUT SOME
OF THEM HAVE FATAL FLAWS BUT
THERE FATAL FLAWS BECAUSE IN MY
OPINION. THEY REDUCE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
INVESTIGATORS. OF BY REDUCING
THEIR INDEPENDENCE ESSENTIALLY-
THERE ARE TWO- THERE ARE THREE
WAYS I THINK THAT THEY DO THIS
ONE IS THAT. ONLY CASES IN
WHICH THERE IS NO REPORT OF A
USE OF FORCE WHICH- HAPPENS BUT
IS VERY IT'S VERY RARE THAT YOU
ACTUALLY FIND OUT ABOUT IT. OR
CASES IN WHICH- SOMEBODY
SUFFERS SERIOUS BODILY HARM OR
INJURY AS DEFINED BY THE PENAL
CODE SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE
AN OFFICER WHO THROUGH IT A
PERSON WHO COULDN'T WALK OUT OF
A WHEELCHAIR- AND KICK THEM BUT
DIDN'T. AND WROTE A REPORT
ABOUT IT BUT THERE WAS NO
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY THEN THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INVESTIGATORS ARE NOT GOING TO
DO THAT INVESTIGATION. AT OR IF
I PUNCH YOU IN THE FACE AND I'M
AN OFFICER AND YOU'RE A PERSON
WHO IS INCARCERATED AND I'D I
JUST GIVE YOU A BLOODY NOSE OR
I GIVE YOU A BLACK GUY- THERE'S
NO SERIOUS BODILY INJURY SO
THAT ALSO WOULDN'T BE
INVESTIGATED BY THE- THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INVESTIGATORS CALLED THEY'RE
CALLED THE AIMS INVESTIGATORS.
AND THE SECOND MAJOR PROBLEM IS
THAT THE WARDEN STILL DECIDES
WHETHER WHICH OF THE TWO
INVESTIGATIVE SYSTEMS THE CASE
GOES TO. THE WARDEN DECIDES
WHETHER HIS STAFFER GONNA
INVESTIGATED OR THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR. OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS INVESTIGATES IT AND-
THAT HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MAJOR
PROBLEMS IS THAT THE WARDENS
HAVE HAD THESE. SITUATIONS
UNDER THEIR DIRECTION AND SUPER
MEDIA SUPERVISION AND YET THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO ELEVATE
THESE. ISSUES TO THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS IN THE
SUFFICIENT WIFE SO THAT MISTER
DE AS AND HIS SUBORDINATES
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
CRISIS. SO WHAT WHAT. WE'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR AND SO FAR
WE HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN CONVINCING OF THE
SECRETARY OR THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT IT'S CRUCIAL. IS THAT THE-
ALL OF THESE USE OF FORCE CASES
SHOULD BE. TURNED OVER TO THE
OFFICE. OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS IN
ORDER. FOR THEM TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION HOW FOR HOW THEY
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED NOT THE
WARDEN. AND I CAN GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF THE FACT THAT- I'VE
SAT IN ON SOME OF THESE
COMMITTEES WERE THE WARDEN
REVIEWS THESE IN INSTANCES AND-
THE SITUATION AS THE WARDEN IS
SITTING THERE AND SO ARE ALL
THE CAPTAINS AND ASSOCIATE
WARDEN SO IT'S BASICALLY A SEA
OF GREEN- UNIFORMS- AND HE HAS
TO DECIDE WHETHER ALL OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY KNOW- THEIR
FRIENDS ARE GOING TO BE-INVESTIGATED BY THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS RATHER THAN BY
HIM. AND IT'S A OR HER AND IT'S
A VERY DIFFICULT DECISION TO
MAKE AND I THINK IT- THE WAY
THE REGULATIONS A DRAFT OF THE
MOMENT. REALLY REDUCES THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE
INVESTIGATION AND PLAYS INTO
THE FACT THAT. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THESE. INSTANCES OF
CONTINUE STAFF MISCONDUCT WHICH
ARE NOT GOING TO BE PROPERLY
INVESTIGATED. THERE ARE ALSO
SOME OTHER TECHNICAL PROBLEMS
BUT SO- WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
DO MISTER DE AS IS CORRECT THAT
WE HAVE HAD MANY DISCUSSIONS-
I'VE HAD WITH HIM I'VE HAD WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. AND WE
REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN. COME TO AN
AGREEMENT- AND I THINK IT WILL
REALLY REDUCE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS YOU
SPENT IN ORDER TO HAVE THIS-
STRAND A SOLVE SOME OF THESE
PROBLEMS. OKAY I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS YEAH IBM.
WELL I THINK WE WERE RELATIVELY
CLEAR LAST TIME WHEN WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS AND I FIND IT VERY
ALARMING THAT THESE THINGS ARE
STILL TAKING PLACE- IN OUR
PRISONS. AND I READ A LOT OF
THE STORIES AND THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE ABSOLUTELY
HORRIBLE THAT THEY'RE COMMITTED
BAR STAFF. YOU KNOW WE TRY TO
OF HOPEFULLY. KEEP THE VIOLENCE
DOWN AMONG. THE INMATES BUT IT
SEEMS THAT A LOT OF THE STUFF
IS INSTIGATED BY PEOPLE WHO
WORK FOR US. AND OUR AND WE
SHOULD NOT BE DOING THIS I
DON'T KNOW WHETHER WE HAVE.
DIFFICULTY FINDING PEOPLE TO
WORK OR OR OR WHAT BUT THIS
DEFICIT. IT'S ABSOLUTELY
HORRIBLE AND I GUESS SO OFTEN I
HEAR ABOUT FOLKS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED WHO COME OUT AND
TELL ME SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE JUST ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE
THAT HAPPENED TO THEM WHAT WAS
SEXUAL ASSAULT. ALL AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND IT'S JUST-
IT'S HORRIBLE THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WE WOULD
PROTECT IN SOME WAY. THE KIND
OF THINGS THAT OCCUR. YEAH I
FIND IT. TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE
AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR EVER AND IT AND IT BOTHERS
ME THAT BECOMES THAT. THE
CULTURE OF INCARCERATION IN
THIS NATION YOU KNOW THAT. A
PERSON. GETS INCARCERATED THE
FIRST THING SOMEONE SAYS TO
THEM ARE YOU GOING TO BECOME
JONES GIRLFRIEND. I MEAN THAT
SAYS WE INCOME DON'T THIS LEVEL
OF BEHAVIOR. YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S STATE ABOUT THE POLICE
OFFICER OR WHOEVER IT IS. IS
LIKE WE EXPECT ABUSE TO OCCUR
IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM. WHICH IS
TO ME TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE. AND
YOU KNOW OF. GOING TO PRISON IS
FRIGHTENING ENOUGH BUT KNOWING
THAT THERE WILL BE YOU KNOW ALL
KINDS OF VIOLENCE ON FOLKS WHEN
THEY BEAR. WITH NOBLE. EFFORT
TO SEEM TO STOP IT IT SOME
POINT WELL YOU HAVE NO MEANS OF
TRYING TO- CORRECT IT UP OR OR
YOU HAVE NO RIGHTS TO SAY WHAT
TOOK PLACE BECAUSE IN THE BE
RETALIATION TO YOU. EITHER BY
OTHER INMATES OR BY THE FOLKS
WHO RUN THE PRISONS THAT I MEAN
THAT IS. THAT IS THAT TO ME IS
VERY FRIGHTENING AND
UNACCEPTABLE AND I CAN'T FIGURE
OUT HOW WE COULD EVER EXPECT.
TO RUN A SYSTEM OF
INCARCERATION. AND EXPECT
PEOPLE TO COME OUT BETTER. IF
THEY'RE IN THAT KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT. IT IT'S YOU KNOW
IT'S WORSE IN THE VIOLENCE THEY
THEY FACE ON THE STREET SO I'M
JUST YEAH I'M VERY CONCERNED
AND I AND I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT THE REGULATIONS I HOPE-
AND- BECAUSE WE'RE SPENDING
MONEY ON THIS BUT ASKING FOLKS
WHO WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY. DONE
VIOLENCE AGAINST OTHERS TO ONCE
AGAIN HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
DETERMINE WHO DOES THE
INVESTIGATION AND THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS IS JUST DUMB IT I CAN
X. SEE HOW WE CAN EXPECT
ANYTHING DIFFERENT. AND MAYBE
YOU CAN BUT I CAN'T SEE HOW
WE'D EXPECT ANY DIFFERENT
RESULTS IF THE IF I DON'T
EMPHASIZE IN THE BEGINNING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAIR
CHAIRWOMAN. FVE EMPHASIZE IN
THE BEGINNING THAT WE DO WE DO
TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY WE DO- I
KNOW. DON AND I'VE HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS AND THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY THAT DON DESCRIBED-
THE END I WANT TO WEED OUT
THESE TYPES OF INDIVIDUALS.
THAT COMMIT THESE ACTS AND WE
HAVE AT THE PARTICULAR
INSTITUTION THAT DON SPEAKS
ABOUT RJD WE HAVE TERMINATED
FOURTEEN INDIVIDUALS AT THAT
PRISON- AT ANOTHER INSTITUTION
WEIGHT ISSUES WE DISMISS THE
SIX INDIVIDUALS- WE DO SICK
PROSECUTION A REFER FOR
PROSECUTION FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
DO. COMMIT THESE ACTS OF THE
DOES TARNISH CPC ARE THAT DOES
TARNISH THE GOOD WORK THAT'S
DONE BY THE THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYEES AND THE THOUSANDS OF
PEACE OFFICERS WHO GO THERE TO
DO THE RIGHT THING TO BE ROLE
MODELS. WHAT I THINK WHAT WAS
SPOKE ABOUT BY MISTER SPECTER.
I THINK PART OF IT IS IT IS IN
A SIMPLIFICATION OF VARIOUS
PROCESSES THAT OCCUR. LIKE I
USED TO FORCE PROCESS. EVERY
REPORTER EVERY USE OF FORCE
THAT IT IS- THAT IS DONE IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS FROM THE LOWEST
LEVEL TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL
THERE'S A REVIEW PROCESS THAT
OCCURS AND I KNOW MISTER
SPECTER DID SPEAK OF A ROOM
FULL OF A SOCIAL WARDENS AND
CAPTAINS AND- WHICH I SAT IN
THERE. AND MYSELF BUT ALSO IN
THAT ROOM IS INSPECTOR GENERAL
THERE IN THAT ROOM ALSO
LISTENING TO THE REVIEW PROCESS
FROM THE BEGINNING FROM THE
TIME THE OFFICER WROTE THE
REPORT OF THE STAFF MEMBER OF
THE REPORT. TO THE INTO WHETHER
THEY CLEAR IT OR NOT ALONG THE
WAY THAT THEY'RE THERE ARE
REFERRALS THAT DO OCCUR FOR
INAPPROPRIATE USES OF FORCE OR
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE IN THAT
PROCESS AND IT'S WELL
DOCUMENTED IT'S WELL AUDITED BY
BY THE O. I. G. THEY PUT ON A
SEMI ANNUAL REPORT- I GET I
COULD. GOING TO ADD NUMBERS BUT
I'LL JUST GO INTO ACTUAL USES
OF FORCE IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN.
SO THEY WERE. 600-020-0407 USES
OF FORCE WE'RE DOING AND IT
POLICY BY THE COMMITTEE OUT OF
ALL THAT 600-020-0404 ONE OF
THOSE THE ORANGE DISAGREED WITH.
NOW I CAN WHAT OF THOSE FORTY
ONE THE VERY DAY AND THE LEVEL
OF DISAGREEMENT WHETHER IT BE
ON THE PUNISHMENT OR WHETHER BE
ON THE PROCESS OR REFERRAL.
WHAT I'M EXPLAINING TODAY IS
THAT THIS NEW REGULATION WILL
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE CONCERNS
DON AND I DO DISAGREE. ON ONE
PARTICULAR AREA FOR THAT WERE
THERE'S A FORK IN THE ROAD
AFTER THE- INVESTIGATION IS
DONE OF IN KOREA IS DONE BY THE
NEW UNIT. THAT WHO DETERMINES
WHETHER SHE GOT OFFICE INTERNAL
AFFAIRS SHOULD IT BE. THE NEW
AIMS UNIT. WHICH IS A CAPTAIN
OR A LIEUTENANT BECAUSE THE WAY
THAT THIS IS DESIGNED AS CAN BE
BROKEN UP INTO THREE REGIONS.
NORTHERN CENTRAL SOUTHERN. THE
BE A CAPTAIN OVERSEEING EACH
ONE OF THOSE UNITS AND
LIEUTENANTS THAT WORK AND DO
THESE ENQUIRIES. SO THE THOUGHT
IS ONCE A COMPLAINT IS REFERRED
UP TO THE AIMS UNIT. THE
LIEUTENANT'S GO AND THEY DO AN
INQUIRY THEY REVIEW THE
DOCUMENTS TO INTERVIEW INMATES
THEY GENERATE A DOCUMENT REFER
IT BACK. AND IT'S UP TO THAT
HUNDRED THIRTY THEN THEY CAN
MAKE THAT DECISION IS IT GONNA
GO TO THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS. OR THEY'RE GONNA DO A
MORE LOCALIZED TRAINING OR OR
OTHER MATTERS. BUT THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER STEP THAT I SPOKE OF
BRIEFLY. THAT IF THERE'S A
DISAGREEMENT OR IN THEIR- IF
THERE IS- A DECISION MADE BY
THAT WHARTON THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TO. ARTICULATE IN THIS POLICY
WHY THEY CHOSE NOT TO REFER.
THAT REFERRAL. AND THOSE
DOCUMENTS THERE WILL BE AUDITED
BY THIS NEW- NEW UNIT. AND IF
THERE'S ANY DISAGREEMENTS WITH
THAT EGGS REFERRED TO THE
DIRECTOR OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTORS. AND
THEN THEY CAN MAKE A
DETERMINATION FOR IT GOES. FOR
MINUTE SPECTRUM NIGHT. ON THAT
PIECE ARE THOSE REGULATE OF.
NOW FOR US TO REVIEW THEY'RE IN
THEIR END DRAFT. I THINK WHAT I
SENT IT TO YOU CHEN THE NINE.
TO GET THE LATEST ONE YEAH TO.
MONICA WE HAVE THE MAKE. WELL
BOTH OF US HAVE THEM HE SENT IT
TO ME SO I AM SURE WILL
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET A CHANCE TO
SEE THEM BEFORE THEIR- FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. THE COMMITTEE
COULD SEE THEM YET PLEASE LOOK.
QUICKLY BECAUSE HE'S GONNA
SUBMIT THEM TO THE- A. L. AND A
WEEK. OUR SERVER OKAY WHICH I
THINK IT WOULD BE NICE IF- WELL
WE NEED TO SEE THEM BEFORE THE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO REVIEW THEM.
BEFORE PAYING THAT KIND OF
MONEY FOR THE REPORT. YEAH AND
I JUST HAVE ONE FINAL COMMENT
WHICH IS GIVEN ALL THE-
TERRIBLE ABUSES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED OVER THE YEARS I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY. I KNOW IF
THIS IS A PROFESSIONAL
DISAGREEMENT AND I UNDERSTAND
MISTER DE AS A- HE ANSWERS TO A
LOT MORE CONSTITUENTS THAN I
DO- BUT GIVEN THE SITUATION- I
JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE-
THE STATE'S STATE AS A WHOLE
ISN'T. GOING FOR THE MOST
INDEPENDENT SITUATION THAT THEY
CAN HAVE AND THE MOST VIGOROUS
INVESTIGATIONS THAT THEY CAN
HAVE BOTH OF THE THINGS I'M
SUGGESTING ARE AIMED IN THAT
DIRECTION AND GIVEN THE
SITUATIONS THAT WE JUST
DISCOVERED AT RJ DE I JUST.
WHICH IS. I'D IN ORDER BEEN
HISTORY THESE KINDS OF CASES I
THINK THAT'S WHAT'S NEEDED WHEN
I. I HAVE A FRIEND WHO'S A THE
DIRECTOR OF THE PENNSYLVANIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
CITIES THE SEC. OF THAT. AND I
CALLED HIM UP WHEN THE SLINGS
VALLEY CASE WAS GETTING GOING
AND THE ORIGIN WAS DOING THE
REPORT I SAID WHAT JOHN WHAT DO
YOU DO AND HE SAID WHAT I DID
WAS I. FOUND SOMEBODY A FORMER
FBI AGENT. HI MADE HIM IN
CHARGE OF THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND I TOOK ALL
OF THE- DISCRETIONARY DECISIONS
AWAY FROM THE WARDENS AND
LOCATED IN THE OFFICE OF AN
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND MICE THE
SITUATION HAS SUBSTANTIALLY
IMPROVED I CAN'T VERIFY THAT
BUT THAT'S WHAT HE SAID. SO I
THINK THAT'S THE DIRECTION THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TO GO AND IF
IT'S GOING TO HAVE ANY HOPE OF
IDENTIFYING THESE PROBLEMS AND
FIXING THEM. THANK YOU THANK
YOU DID YOUR THING THEN. LIST
OF. I DO I GUESS I'M- A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED IN HOW THIS IS
ULTIMATELY ROLLING OUT. BECAUSE
THE. WE HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL
IN THE MESSAGE THAT WE'RE
SENDING WITH THE REGULATIONS
AND I APPRECIATE. YOUR THAT YOU
ARE THE SECTOR ABSOLUTELY
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS. BUT BECAUSE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO CHANGE
ITS ESSENCE IS CULTURAL AND
CULTURE THAT'S BEEN BUILT UP
OVER DECADES TO DO THAT I THINK
WE NEED TO TAKE. A BIT MORE
DRAMATIC STEP THANOTHERWISE IN
ANYTHING THAT. I THINK WITHOUT
A DEFAULT MADAM CHAIR TO A VERY
VERY CLEAR INDEPENDENCE. WE'RE
NOT SENDING BACK RIGHT MESSAGE.
AND WE OFTEN UP HERE TALK ABOUT
THE PRISON SYSTEM IN GENERAL
BUT IT CAN NOT ALWAYS THAN
ABOUT SPECIFIC POPULATIONS BUT
BY EXAMPLE AND SOME OF IT IS AN-
THE STAFF REPORT. I THINK WOMEN
WHO ARE CARS RATED FACE SOME
VERY DRAMATIC CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT ARE HARD TO GET OUT OF IT
HARD TO CHANGE FACT HAVE BEEN
RECENTLY TALKING JUST BEGINNING
TO CUT HAVE CONVERSATIONS. SOME
PEOPLE WHO HAVE. GONE INTO SOME
OF THE WOMEN'S FACILITIES
THERE. AT THE- SEE TO BE FAIRLY
PERVASIVE HOW MUCH I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
ASCERTAIN. BECAUSE IN A NUMBER
OF THE WOMEN WHO EVEN WHEN THEY
COME OUT OR SO TRAUMATIZED BY
WHAT HAPPENED AND SO FEARFUL OF
TALKING. WHAT I'VE ASKED IF
THERE'S A WILLINGNESS COME TALK
TO ME TO HELP EXPLAIN SO THAT
THAT I CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED INSIDE THERE'S A REAL
UNWILLINGNESS FOR WOMEN WHO
HAVE COME OUT. TO EVEN
ARTICULATE WHAT HAPPENED INSIDE
THERE SO AFRAID. OF
CONSEQUENCES. THEY'RE OUTSIDE.
NOT INSIDE ANYMORE THAT IT'S
HARD I THINK FOR US TO SIT HERE
AND IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE. AND
THE TRAUMA AND THE FEAR. INSIDE
SO THE THIS COMMITTEE HASN'T
ALWAYS FOCUSED ON THE
INSTITUTIONS FOR WOMEN AND THAT
IS ONE OF MY SUGGESTIONS BUT
I'M TEARS THAT WE TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT. AND SEE IF THERE'S A
WAY THAT WE CAN. GET BETTER
INFORMATION. IN A PRODUCTIVE
WAY ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
THERE SO IF THERE'S AN
INVESTIGATION THAT HAS ANY
POSSIBILITY. OF BEING DEALT
WITH INSIDE. I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE VERY
DRAMATICALLY THE CHARACTER OF
SOMEBODY WHO IS INSIDE A WOMAN
WHO'S INSIDE. THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO COME FORWARD AT ALL IN THE
FIRST PLACE. BECAUSE OF THAT
THAT IF IT. THAT FEAR WILL BE I
THINK VERY DEBILITATING TO THE
CASE IF THEY HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT THERE WILL ALWAYS BE AN
OUTSIDE INVESTIGATION. AND
PRINT AND THE ABILITY TO
PROTECT THEM FROM RETALIATION
ALTHOUGH I THINK THE CULTURE IS
SUCH THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BELIEVE. THAT YOU CAN SAY THE
REGULATIONS CAN SAY AND THE
STRUCTURE CAN BE THAT THEY WILL
BE PROTECTED FROM ITALIAN ASIAN
THEY WILL NOT BELIEVE. IF
THEY'RE STILL CARING THAT FEAR
ONCE THEY COME OUT. I DON'T SEE
HOW THEY ON THE ANYONE ON THE
INSIDE. WE'LL WE'LL BE ABLE TO
TRUST OF THAT UNTIL THAT
PROCESS STARTS TO SHOW REAL
RESULTS. SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE COULD TAKE A
LITTLE BIT LOOK AND LET'S I
THINK WE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT.
THE FACILITIES FOR WOMEN
SPECIFICALLY AND MAYBE THIS
COMMITTEE AND OR PUBLIC SAFETY
AND SEE IF WE CAN GET A BETTER
SENSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING. HOW
IT'S HAPPENING. AND HOW WE
REALLY FIND A TRULY INDEPENDENT
AND EFFECTIVE WAY OF GETTING
THE STORIES TOLD AND THEN
STARTING TO DRIVE THAT. TO
DRIVE THAT CHANGE SO IT'S THOSE
PATTERNS THAT WERE TRYING TO
BREAK DOWN THOSE PATTERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED A LONG
TIME. AND THE INSTITUTION. BOTH
THE THAT THE WOMEN HER IN THE
INSTITUTION AN INSTITUTION
ITSELF HAVE RELIED ON. THOSE
PATTERNS FOR SO LONG THAT
BREAKING THOSE PATTERNS OF
BREAKING THE EXPECTATIONS I
DON'T THINK IS GOING TO BE AN
EASY TASK AT ALL- ESPECIALLY
WHEN PEOPLE ARE SO AFRAID TO
COME FORWARD. SO I. I'M VERY
INTERESTED TO SEE THE
REGULATIONS I THINK WE NEED TO
SEE THE REGULATIONS. BUT IF
THOSE REGULATIONS DO NOT FOSTER
ENOUGH OF A GUARANTEE OF THAT
INDEPENDENCE OF THAT OUTSIDE
LOOK AND THAT REAL SENSE OF
PROTECTION FROM RETALIATION AND
THAT'D BE DEMONSTRATED THAT TO
BE ARTICULATED AND THAT
DEMONSTRATED. I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET THE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING. IN THE CASES THAT WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND. THIS OF THE
CRISIS THAT THAT I FEEL IS
THERE. BUT IS NOT ABLE TO BE
REALLY EXPLAIN THAT AT THE
LEVEL THAT I THAT I THINK WILL
BE HELPFUL BECAUSE IF IT'S AT
ALL PARTIALLY TRUE IT IS
FRIGHTENING AND IF THE WHAT I'M
HEARING IF IT SEEMS AS
PERVASIVE AS IT IS ENTIRELY
UNACCEPTABLE AND REALLY
ABSOLUTELY OUT OF CONTROL SO I
UNDERSTAND YOUR PROCESS AND
SETTING THE REGULATIONS. BUT
FOR ME I THINK IT I THINK BY
HOPEFULLY FOR THIS COMMITTEE
THAT IF WE'RE NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH THE LEVEL OF INDEPENDENCE
THAT'S THERE THAT THAT'S NOT
GOING TO BE ACCEPTABLE HERE AND
IS NOT GOING TO FLY BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO BE A
CORNERSTONE TO REALLY BEING
ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION AND TO THAT THE
STATE OF WHAT'S INSIDE INSIDE.
I THINK IT'S BEEN. IT'S GONE ON
FOR SO LONG TIME. THAT WITHOUT
A REAL DRAMATIC STATE WITH THE
THESE REGULATIONS SHOULD NOT BE
JUST. A NEXT STEP. AND OPENING
AWAY YET BUT SHOULD BE A
DRAMATIC STEP TO SHOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WE- EVERYONE IS
VERY VERY SERIOUS ABOUT. MAKING
THAT THE KINDS OF CULTURAL
STRUCTURAL THOSE CHANGES. TO
ENSURE. THE SAFETY ON THE
INSIDE. SO I HAVE. SOMEONE
STONE. WE HAVE SOME WOMEN WE'VE
BEEN TALKING TO AT THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR PUBLICLY IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO TALK TO
THEM WE'LL BE HAPPY TO GO DOWN
THERE WITH YOU AND- I THINK
THEY WOULD PROBABLY- BE WILLING
TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT SOME OF
THE- ISSUES THAT THEY MAY.
BECAUSE I'M HEARING THIS FROM
SOME FOLKS TO INSIDE AND WHEN
THEY'RE REELING BACK TO ME SO I
WOULD HAVE YOU I THINK. FROM
THIS COMMITTEE FORMALLY. SHOULD
MAKE THAT REQUESTED A
POTENTIALLY GO DO SOME TOURS IN
AND SORT OF SEE WHAT. WHAT WE
CAN DO BECAUSE I ALSO IT FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE
WITH THE REHABILITATION SIDE
AND- THE REFORMS AND ALL THAT
THE MESSAGE THAT I'M GETTING
BACK IN AGAIN THIS IS THIRD
HAND. THEY'RE NOT FEELING. ANY
APPROPRIATE ATTENTION BEING
PAID IN THE WOMEN'S FACILITIES
BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING MORE
GENERALLY. AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE NEEDED
LEGISLATURE TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR ADDRESSING THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE NOT ALWAYS BEEN. THERE AND
BEEN AVAILABLE AND I THINK IF
WE TAKE SOME SOME MORE FROM HIS
STEPS AND SHOW THAT THERE'S-
ATTENTION BEING PAID THAT WE'RE
WILLING TO LISTEN AND BE A PART
OF THIS PROCESS. I THINK JUST
THAT WILL WILL ALSO. GO A LONG
WAYS BUT ALSO MISS SECTOR I'M
I'M HOPING THAT WHAT YOU
PERCENT AND I THINK THAT. WHAT
WE WOULD EXPECT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS. EVEN BEYOND KIND OF
CURRENT STATUS BUT IS THE WITH
THE GREATEST AMOUNT OF
INDEPENDENCE OF REVIEW BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE A CREDIBILITY
QUESTION FOR THAT WHOLE SYSTEM
RIGHT I AGREE AND APPRECIATE
BOTH YOUR COMMENTS AND I TAKE
THAT VERY SERIOUSLY TO THE I
MEAN I TO THE POINT TO WHERE I.
KNEW I WAS GOING TO BE HERE.THEN I SENT OUT- THE LINK TO
THIS HEARING TO ALL THE WARDEN
SO THEY CAN UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE SO THEY CAN
SEE. WHAT WE'RE DOING WHAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT. ONE OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS IS FAR TOO MANY.
THAT WERE FAR TOO MANY I TAKE
IT VERY SERIOUSLY- YES WE ARE
SEEKING FUNDING FOR CAMERAS IN
THESE FACILITIES TO EXPAND OUR
CAMERAS ON THE YARDS AT RJD. AT
THE WOMEN'S FACILITY AT C. O.
W. AT SALINAS VALLEY. TO ASSIST
WITH SOME OF THESE CULTURAL
ISSUES. BUT YOU KNOW LIKE YOU
SITTING HERE LISTENING TO THE
CRITICISMS OF THE AGENCY THAT I
BELIEVE IS DOING GOOD WORK BUT
DEFINITELY CAN BE DOING BETTER-IT DOES AFFECT ME. YOU KNOW NOT
ONLY IS PROFESSIONAL BUT
PERSONALLY. BECAUSE I CARE
ABOUT THE POPULATION I DO CARE
ABOUT THESE PRISONS I DO CARE
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE PRODUCING ONCE
A RELEASE. AND I'M SAD TO HEAR
ABOUT. THE STORIES OF PEOPLE
LEAVING IT ONLY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT I EXPERIENCE. OTHER
STORIES THAT ARE OPPOSITE OF
THAT SO I'M SURE SOMEWHERE IN
THE MIDDLE THAT WE NEED TO
IMPROVE THAT. OBVIOUSLY MOST OF
US ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE. OF
THE REGULATIONS AND SO I'M
GOING TO SUGGEST THAT THE THAT
YOU BEFORE YOU SUBMIT THEM THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAVE ACCESS TO
THEM. AND THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS SOME.
PRIOR TO THE SUBMIT AND MEAN IT
YOU KNOW WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE FORT SUBMIT IT. RATHER THAN
HAVING TO RESPOND TO IT AFTER
THE FACT. AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN
IT SO- WE WOULD LIKE TO. BE
ABLE TO WEIGH IN ON IT AND A-
GET SOME SENSE OF- FEELING THAT
IT THAT IT IS SO. THAT IS
ACCEPTABLE. AS YOU SINCE IT'S
SO MUCH WORK HAS GONE INTO.
ANOTHER WE COULD TO WON'T GO
PROBABLY DELAY IT THAT MUCH.
I'M I'M NOT SURE THE MECHANICS
OF IT I DON'T KNOW BUT CLEARLY.
AND DONT. SENATE OVER DUE. TO
THE STAFF. OKAY BUT WE- I
BELIEVE ANY REVIEW THERE I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
CONTACTS WITH EXPLANATION. SURE
EDUARDO PORTION OF AND THAT'S
WHY I SAY IT. WAS IF IT'S SENT
TO US THEN WE WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET ABOUT IT.
AND HAVE CONVERSATION WITH YOU
AND WHOEVER ELSE IS INVOLVED IN
IT. YEAH EITHER THE AUTHORS OF
IT- TO FIND OUT EXACTLY WHAT
THE RATIONALE IS FOR. AND
WHATNOT- THEY THEY BELIEVE IT'S
GOING TO ANSWER THE ISSUES THAT
WE RAISED IN THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE. A DRAMATIC CHANGE AND
WHAT'S WHAT IS TAKING PLACE-
THAT WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT IS POINTED OUT WITH
MISSED A STONE THE HISTORIC
NATURE. OF THE ABUSES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN A- AND LIMITED
RESPONSE. FROM US TO THOSE
ISSUES WILL MAKE SURE. THAT WE
ARE FINDING THAT PEOPLE KNOW
THAT. IS A. THIS IS HERE IN
TOWN. NEW GROUP PEOPLE WHO
DIFFERENCE OF EYES. IF OF
VALUES. IT MAY BE THAT THE IS A
C. F. AND WE WANT TO. MAKE THAT
IT TAKES FOR. AND THAT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR US AS WELL AS FOR
THOSE WHO ARE- THAT WE HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT ARE IN
OUR CUSTODY- I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING. WE DO HAVE
UP PUBLIC COMMENTS. I GOT YOUR
FOR ANYONE WANTS TO MAKE A
COMMENT YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE TO
COMMENT NOT VERY LONG-
CONCERNING IT MAKE SURE YOU
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR-
JUST. YOUR NAME AND IF YOU HAVE
AN AFFILIATION- BUT WILL TAKE
COMMENTS FOR ONE MINUTE IF YOU
PLAN TO MAKE COMMENTS PLEASE
GET IN LINE- SO WE HAVE ONE
PERSON WHO'S GOING TO COME IT.
IS THAT CORRECT. IF YOU PLAN TO
COMMENT PLEASE GET IN LINE ALSO
WE HAVE SOME SENSE OF THE
AMOUNT OF TIME WE ARE. UP
AGAINST A DEADLINE TO CLOSE UP
THE HEARING. OKAY THANK YOU.
YES OKAY SO MY NAME IS DIANA
CREWS. I HAVE AN INCARCERATED
LOVED ONE- SOMETHING THAT YOU
MISTER SPECTER STATED A YOU
CANNOT DO REHABILITATION. WHEN
YOU DON'T FEEL SAFE WELL OUR
LOVED ONES IN PRISON TODAY ARE
NOT FEELING SAFE. AND MADE YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THERE WAS A
MUTANT NON DESIGNATED
PROGRAMMING FACILITY. AND ALSO
INCREMENTAL RELEASES THAT HAVE
BEEN GOING ON IN THE STATE
PRISONS. WHICH ARE CAUSING LOTS
OF VIOLENCE. THE VIOLENCE STAFF
KNOWS AND UNDERSTANDS AOUT THE
VIOLENCE. ALL THE HIGHER
VIOLENCE AS GOING ON THEY- ARE
OUR LIVES ARE LOSING THEIR
PAROLE DATES. THEY'RE GETTING
EXTRA DA REFERRALS FOR
ATTEMPTED MURDER GETTING A BITE
OF SKATING LABELED PROGRAM
FAILURES. THEY'RE GETTING SENT
TO THE HOLDER LOSING THEIR GOOD
TIME ALL OF IT DEFEATING THE
WHOLE CLOSING DOWN OF A PRE. AT
IT I SAID THEY KNOWINGLY. THE
VIOLIN WILL LOOK. AND THE-
THEY'RE TELLING THE THEY DON'T
KNOW WHY VIOLENCE OCCURS YOU
HAVE PEOPLE IN FULL RIOT GEAR
OFFICERS ADMINISTRATORS ON THE
SIDELINES HOSPITALS ON STAND BY
MEDICAL STAFF ON STAND BY YOU
UNDERSTAND AND YOU KNOW THAT
THE VIOLENCE IS GOING TO OCCUR.
ON THE MAJOR RIGHT THE TWO
HUNDRED IN MADE RIGHT. AT C. T.
F. ON EIGHT FOURTEEN MISTER DE
AS WAS AT THE FACILITY THE
THIRTEEN OF AUGUST THE DAY
BEFORE AND HE KNEW AND
UNDERSTOOD OF THE VIOLENCE THAT
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN THE NEXT
DAY. AND HE'S STILL ALLOWED IT
TO HAPPEN SOME OF YES I'M JUST
YOU KNOW I'M ASKING LEGISLATORS
FOR A PUBLIC SAFETY HEARING SO
THEY CAN HEAR OUT HERE. STORIES
OF A LOVED ONES AND THEY ARE IN
DURING TODAY IN THE STATE
PRISONS. IN AUDIT AND P.
EXACTLY HOW MANY INCIDENTS ARE
GOING ON HOW MUCH VIOLENCE IS
HAPPENING IN THESE PRISONS BUT-
BECAUSE IT IS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF REHABILITATION.
THANK YOU THINK. HELLO MY NAME
IS TONY AND- I HAVE A LOVE WHEN
INCARCERATED. I'M MY HUSBAND
HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY
INCREMENTAL RELEASES-
ADMINISTRATION UNDER CHAIN OF
COMMAND IS A COMPLETE FAILURE
THE LACK OF COMMUNICATION- HAS
THEM THE PRISON THE PRISON
SYSTEM. ARE RUNNING HOWEVER
THEY WANT- COUPLE TODAY A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO MY HUSBAND
OUT AFTER VISIT- THEY- DID HIM
ARM A BODY SCAN WHICH EVERYBODY
SUPPOSED TO GO THERE AND THEY
DID IT TO HIM THREE TIMES
LEADER TO HIM THREE TIMES AND-
IT WAS NOT ENOUGH. AFTER THAT
THEY DID AND- WHAT IS IT IT
DIDN'T STRIP SEARCH AFTER NOT
FINDING ANYTHING YOU KNOW- THEY
JUST THEY TOLD THEM CONSIDER
THIS YOUR LUCKY DAY. AND HE
SAID EXCUSE ME AND YOU KNOW HE
DOESN'T HE DON'T WANT TO CAUSE
ANY PROBLEMS HE JUST LEFT ARM I
WAS ALSO A- THERE IS A LOT A
LACK OF COMMUNICATION WHEN-
THEY HAVE BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
MODIFY PROGRAM WHERE THEY'RE AT
RIGHT NOW AND THEY WERE NOT
COMMUNICATING WHEN THEY WERE
CHANGING THE DATES. I AM MYSELF
AND MY SON AND MY FATHER LLADRO
FIVE HOURS FROM LA TO VISIT MY
LOVE ONE AND I WAS TURNED AWAY
AND THE ONLY THING THEY COULD
TELL ME IT WAS A CHANGE THAT
WAS MADE BY ADMINISTRATION A
DAY PRIOR AND WE WERE NOT EVEN
NOTIFIED OF IT- I DID MADE US
OF A CITIZEN COMPLAINT. AND I
FEEL THAT WHAT HAPPENED TO MY
HUSBAND WAS ACTUALLY
RETALIATION- AND- THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU PLEASE HELP US STOP
ANY FURTHER OF FORCED
INTEGRATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. MY HUSBAND AND
IS INCARCERATED- AND I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE WAY CDC ARE IS DOING THINGS
AND IT IS A CULTURAL THING.
THAT'S GOING ON- YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT IT'S NOT JUST A FEW
OFFICERS. IT'S A WHOLE CULTURE
AND- YOU KNOW THERE'S A IN A
SAFETY AND SECURITY IS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE BIGGEST CONCERN. AND
YET WHY WOULD THEY PUT SOMEBODY
BACK ON A YARD. YOU KNOW WHO
WAS HURT THE DAY BEFORE. IN A
ON A YARD THAT WAS BEING
INTEGRATED THERE WAS BE MERGED
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT WHEN
THEY WHEN THE PERSON WAS
INJURED THIS THAT DAY. OKAY THE
DAY BEFORE OKAY IN THIS IS THIS
HAS TO DO WITH THE BIRDS THE
GENERAL POPULATION BE MERGED
WITH PROTECTIVE CUSTODY. WHERE
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE IS WHERE IS DUE PROCESS
YOU KNOW THIS THIS WHOLE THING
ABOUT THEM YOU KNOW OFFICER
MISCONDUCT IS REQUIRING. A DUE
PROCESS- BUSINESS FOR THE FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
FALSELY ACCUSED THERE'S NO NO-
WE'RE LEGAL REPRESENTATION
WITHIN THE PRISON THE APPEALS
PROCESS ALL IN HOUSE. COULD YOU
SUM UP THANK YOU. A MINUTE OKAY.
THE SERVER IS. DO YOU THINK.
THE LOW POINT AWAY FROM SIMPLY
IT'S A CURSORY DID. YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO LIVE IN
FEAR FOR YOUR LOVED ONES. SO
I'M ASKING YOU TO PLEASE.
IMPLEMENT SOME HEAVY OVERSIGHT
ON CDC ARE DO NOT ALLOW THEM TO
JUST TAKE ALL THAT MONEY AND
USE IT AS THEY SEE FIT THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME SERIOUS
OVERSIGHT ON THE BUDGET. AND
I'M NOT JUST STANDING HERE AS A
WIFE OF INMATE HAS YOU SO REFER
TO HIM I AM A MOTHER OF A SEAL
AS WELL. SO I FEAR FOR MY SON'S
LIFE EVERY DAY I FEAR FOR MY
HUSBAND'S LIFE EVERYDAY. HAS
THE STUFF THAT'S GOING ON
BEHIND THOSE WALLS. IS NOT SAFE
IT'S NOT JUST THIS. THESE MEN
MY HUSBAND SERVING TWO LIFE
SENTENCES. AS A THREE STRIKER.
TO NON VIOLENT OFFENSES HE
BROKE A WINDOW STILL SPEAKERS
OUT OF A CAR AND THEY CAME A
LIFE SENTENCE. HE'S BEEN DOWN
TWENTY FOUR YEARS BUT HE'S A-
THREAT TO SOCIETY CONCERT THEM
ACCORDING TO CDC. SO I ASH TO
THE PLEASE REALLY LOOK AND SEE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING BEHIND THOSE
WALLS BECAUSE- IF YOU DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE INMATES AS YOU
GUYS CALL CARE ABOUT THE STUFF
THAT YOU GUYS EMPLOYEE. THAT
OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE GOING TO
BECAUSE SOMEBODY NEEDS TO SPEAK
UP FORM. AND NO BORDEN IS GOING
TO RAISE THEIR HAND AND SEE
THAT THEY HAVE A PROBLEM IN THE
PRISON THANKS. THANK YOU. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME IS
MARY AND I AM ALSO- I ALSO HVE
A LOVED ONE INCARCERATED- I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT WITH THE-
PRESENT CLOSURE- AND WHILE THE
POPULATION WITH REDUCTION- HAS
INCREASED IT IS NOT WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE AND WHERE IT SHOULD
BE. THIS IS HAPPENED THIS ISN'T
HAPPENING FAST ENOUGH AND-
INMATES HAVE BEEN FACED WITH SO
MANY OBSTACLES AND ROAD BLOCKS-
TO OBTAIN THEIR RELEASE- MORE
THAN FOCUSING ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE I BELIEVE THAT
CDC ARE SHOULD FOCUS ON FAILED
PROGRAMS- THAT HAVE BEEN.
CONTRIBUTING FOR OR FACTORS- OF
THE TWO OBSTACLES TO- TO THEM
NOT NOT BEING RELEASED. I BEGAN
CDC ARE HAS TO REVISIT CERTAIN
PROGRAMS WITH URGENCY. CDC OURS
MAIN FOCUS NEEDS TO GO TOWARDS
IMMEDIATELY HALL TO. MANDATORY
INTEGRATION WHICH IS AND THE P.
HAVE NON DESIGNATED PROGRAM
FACILITIES. AS WELL AS AN
EFFECTIVE IN PERMANENT SOLUTION
TO INCREMENTAL RELEASES THANK
YOU- I'M NOT DONE MA'AM I'M
SORRY AND THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I SAW HIM IN IT
PEOPLE KEEP ADDING TO THE LINE
BEHIND YOU I UNDERSTAND- THESE
TWO PROGRAMS ARE RESPONSIBLE IN
LARGE FOR THE INCREASE. IN
WRITE UPS- BOARD DATE TO BE
LAWS- INMATES BEING DENIED OF
PAROLE AND SPECIALLY THEM
LOOSING PROGRAMMING- WHILE
THESE THESE PROMISES OF CHANGE.
ARE BEING MADE AND THEY'RE NOT
HAPPENING FAST ENOUGH AND IN
THE MEANTIME PEOPLE ARE BEING
ARE NOT BEEN PROPERLY
REHABILITATED OR CARE FOR IT ON
THE CONTRARY THEY ARE SUFFERING
HURTING HIM AND PUT IN DANGER.
AND AT RISK A DAILY BASIS. AND
AS MR ON. LACKEY WHO'S NOT HERE
STATED- THIS INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THE CONDITIONS ARE DISCUSSING
THE MORE DISGUSTING AND
EMBARRASSING IS THE TRAUMA
VIOLENCE AND DANGER THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND STAFF ARE PUT
ON DALY. FOR THIS REASON WE
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ALSO REQUEST
FOR A PUBLIC HERE SAFETY
HEARING SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THIS MATTER AND THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
FRASER I'M HERE WITH THE
AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE MEMBER OF CURB
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET. I AM A
TRAVEL HERE TODAY TO EMPLOY
THIS COMMITTEE TO AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH PLANS TO CLOSE
PRISONS NOT JUST ONE BUT
SEVERAL PRISONS. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT QURBAN ARE EVEY
MEMBER ORGANIZATION STRONGLY-
SUPPORT AND THERE'S THREE
THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO RAISE
TODAY AROUND AND BEING ABLE TO
MAKE THAT POSSIBLE IN THE LONG
RUN ONE IS WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
EXTREME SENTENCING WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH ALL WHAT. IN SAYING
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THREE
STRIKES ME NEEDS TO AND EXTREME
SENTENCING TO BE ABLE TO START
CLOSING OUR FACILITIES. AND I
CAN HAS TO DO WITH THE OLD ROLE
WHICH IS A NEW ISSUE THAT
YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
DOCTOR WEBER I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SEE A LAYOVER PORT THEY CAME ON
FRIDAY. AT COMMITTEES AROUND
EXAMINING ABILITY CRITERION
EXPANDING THOSE FOR OLDER
PAROLE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LET
HER TO A AND WOULD YOU. TO
FIFTY YEARS OF AGE TRIPS FIFTY
YEARS REGARDLESS THEIR SENTENCE
TYPE. AND WE'VE SEEN SO MANY
PORT CENTER A BILL FOR A GO FOR
BRADY. IN SOME. HOPE WE CAN SET
OUR MAKING THOSE RIGHT WHICH I
UNDER WOULD CALL A LOT OF FOR
LOOKING AT BILLION IN SO WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE TO DO THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WHEN I HAVE TO
KEEP EVERYONE TO ONE MINUTE
PLEASE. HI MY NAME'S ASHLEY
THANK YOU FRONT SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US TALK HERE- WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY IS NOT JUST
ABOUT A SYSTEM THAT BROKEN BUT
A SYSTEM THAT NEEDS THE REAL
EXPERTS TO REPLACE IT. YOU JUST
HEARD THE EXPERTS. THEY'RE
RIGHT HERE- THERE ALSO THE
PEOPLE INSIDE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
KNOW HOW TO RUN THE PRISON THEY
KNOW HOW TO TAKE CARE OF EACH
OTHER YOU KNOW HOW TO FEED EACH
OTHER WHEN THEY'RE NOT TAKING
OUT OF INTRUSION. WHEN THEY'RE
NOT IN THE MORE THEY'RE BEING
ABUSED BY THE CEOS- THEY ARE
THE REAL EXPERTS THE SEARS
BUDGET IS TOO BIG IT'S TIME TO
MOVE THOSE EFFORTS TO THE REAL
EXPERTS US ANY. WELL NOW
COMMUNITY WHO. ARE NOW FREE UP
WHO USED TO BE INSIDE THERE
ALSO THE EXPERT WE KNOW WHAT TO
DO. I'M GET IS ABOUT. FAMILIES
THEIR TICKETS TO SPEAK ON
DEFINITELY THESE LISTEN TO AT
THEIR- SAFETY COMMITTEE.
MEETING UR EXES ME AT THAT
THERE PROPOSED HEARING. AND FEE
THEIR DESIGNS BECAUSE THEY ARE
READY NOW FOR THEIR FAMILY TO
COME HOME. AND THEY ARE READY
TO PROVIDE THE REHABILITATION
THAT THE PEOPLE INSIDE DESERVE
AND THINK. THANK HELLO MY
NAME'S RICHARD CREWS I'M WITH
THE HYMNS A COLLECTIVE. I SPENT
THIRTY YEARS IN PRISON. AND
WHAT I SEE MISSING HERE. IS THE
VOICES OF THOSE WHO DIED. AND I
NOTICED THAT. RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE IS NOW PART OF THE
MISSION STATEMENT. FIRST
JUSTICE IS GETTING THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE DIRECTLY AFFECTED. AND
THEIR INPUT ALSO AND SO THAT'S
WHAT I SEE MISSING HEARS US
TELLING PEOPLE WHAT THEY NEED
FOR REHABILITATION I SPENT
THIRTY YEARS I FIGURED IT OUT
THROUGH ALL THIS I WAS IN
CORPORATE HOUSING PLEASANT
VALLEY HOUSING THESE
INSTITUTIONS YOU NAME. AND I
LIVED THERE. DOWN WILL WORK FOR
ME BUT NOT ALL THAT WAS GREAT.
OUR I WENT THROUGH THE
VIOLENCE. I WAS SET UP I WAS I
WAS FORMED IN WAYS. BY GUARDS.
I LIVED THROUGH IT BUT I'M NOT
HERE NOW. AND I THINK THAT'S
THE VOICE THAT'S MISSING HERE.
IF WE GET WITH THEM. AND WE CAN
TALK ABOUT. WHAT CAN REALLY
WORK THANK YOU. HI MY NAME THAT
THE ROBUST IN OUR HELP WITH THE
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION I HAVE
I DON'T HAVE MUCH TO ADD TO A-
YOU HEARD THE FAMILY MEMBER
STATE BUT- YOU KNOW I HEARD
THAT THERE IS A POTENTIAL TO
CLOSE MORE THAN ONE PERSON IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS BECAUSE OF
THE TREND OF THE- DECREASING
PRISON POPULATION AND- THE NDP
UP THE NON DESIGNATED PROGRAM
FACILITIES DOES JEOPARDIZE THIS
DOWNWARD TREND BECAUSE- PEOPLE
ARE BEING LABELED AS PROGRAM
FAILURES BECAUSE THEY FEAR FOR
THEIR- SAFETY THAT. INTEGRATE
INTO THESE ARE THAN TO BE
FORCED TO IMPAIR OR CAPTAIN
CASES. PEOPLE IT IS GETTING
THERE'S- FIGHT OUT HIS GROUP.
AND PEOPLE WEREN'T EVEN PART OF
THE FIGHT TO CATCHING CASES IN
THIS PLAN. AND LOSING SOME.
DATES THE PAROLE BOARD AND
POTENTIAL RELEASE STATES SO.
THE ANTI PEPPER AND YOU KNOW.
REFORM FOR HARD. HARD BY REFORM
PROPERTY SEVEN SB TWO SIXTEEN
TO SIXTY ONE SO I JUST. OF MY
VOICE TO THE REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE SENATE OR
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE HOLDS THAT A PUBLIC.
HEARING INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON ANDY PF AND I'M ALSO THAT
THE LEGISLATURE. MOVED TO
REQUEST AN AUDIT OF NDP OF BY
THE- INSPECTOR GENERAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THANK ALL OF
YOU WHO CAME TODAY FOR- WE WILL
TAKE ALL OF YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
CONSIDERATION. OF THANK THOSE
STAFF. HERE TO DO THE
REPORTING. OF WE WILL GO UP.
AND GO OVER SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT W'VE MENTION. OF
THAT WE THINK NEED TO HAPPEN IN
TERMS OF THE- US REVIEWING THIS
THE PROCEDURES PRIOR TO THAT.
AND MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
SOME OF YOU. ABOUT A THING SO
WE BEFORE WE DONE SOME SITE.
IT'S SET UP DOT OF IN THIS PAST
YEAR. AND SOME OTHER PLACES SO.
THANK YOU FOR COMING THANK YOU
FOR SHARING- ANYTIME YOU FEEL
YOU TO SUBMIT. YOUR DOCUMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE ALL THE THINGS IT
JUST READ FEEL FREE TO. SUBMIT
ADMITTING WILL. EXCESS BUT IS
ABOUT. UP AGAIN THANK OFFER
COME THE MEETING IS THERE.